[Music]
four
three
two
what is up everybody thank you thank you
it is monday
thanks for joining us
[Applause]
you know it's good to be here
sure is every monday we're here
you can count on that
actually next week we won't be here on
monday we weren't here last monday
either actually yeah yeah you know for
the most part right it's a
generalization am i actually gone next
monday for me and eli's anniversary uh
let me look at the calendar yeah me and
ela are having our 10th is that right
that's in october though
yeah it's uh three weeks why don't
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's not this month it's yeah
it's in october
what it's not next monday it's the
monday after that
stupid oh it's almost october yeah yeah
okay in two weeks yes sir yeah so so
we'll be here next monday but me and
either going to be married 10 years dude
congratulations what's the um
what's the the theme for that one you
know like golden is like i think 25 or
something i looked it up it's like horse
hair or something horse hair tin tin oh
tim yeah right yeah i don't know these
these marriage uh the hell
these marriage traditions are weird
they're like on the 10th wedding
anniversary you have to give her a
horsehair [ __ ] uh
bracelet
tin i mean what is tin
it is tin what's tin what do you buy
made of tin
tin or aluminum like a [ __ ] candle
holder what am i supposed to do aluminum
you could get her a zero baby private
jet
well there's a little bit of a gap there
and maybe a coke zero on a private jet
i'm leaning more the coke zero okay than
the private jet but anyway yeah me and
hila almost married uh 10 years man wow
together for 15 so love is possible
apparently
you know
wow apparently congrats for real that's
that's uh that's an accomplishment for
sure
um thank you by the way to our wonderful
sponsors here we have
hellofresh honeyandstamps.com and
speaking of honey
this back speaking of hella fresh oh
[ __ ] back it up strike that start over
speaking of hellofresh
thus this back to school season hello
fresh
handle let hellofresh handle dinner
their quick and easy meals take the
stress out of meal time even on hectic
weeknights
get 65
off wow
so they switched up their offer a little
bit 65 off boom can they do that
i'm have to check with them
but it's what it says here
65 percent off plus free shipping with
the code h3tv65
at hellofresh.com
h3tv65 and i mean look at this all these
delicious wins you guys know it great
time to try 65 off thank you thank you
all right
so anyway uh thank you everybody for
for being here yes we have a exciting
schedule for today i've been getting
absolutely
absolutely devastated by the amount of
chat logs i've been seeing would be uh
between like
women
and the men they're dating
and it's just not happening you know i'm
i'm hated by men everywhere real quick
just before we jump into that
where's zach
where's zach i didn't even notice he was
going
shouldn't there be some zach
zach
i don't hear any like claps and stuff
or the sound bites yeah well let's just
do the show and then okay
if he shows up maybe he's pooping
okay maybe he's having issues all right
shout out zach
what's that
what the [ __ ]
this is laughter
[Music]
all right welcome zach everybody
zach
the joker what is what is this zach
you're over compensating a bit after
lena challenged your joker supremacy
what's what's the strategy here oh
there's no challenge
well she did challenge you actually yeah
no she did no she definitely challenged
you yeah but
there's no challenge
now lena you did not show up and uh
dressed as joker your thoughts
i'm not surprised he showed up that way
but yes i'm just dressed up as normal
because i never said i was joker brained
people told people assigned me as joker
brain right and also i do want to say
zach had a whole powerpoint and he
explained himself very thoroughly and
still the people chose me i don't know
what more to say about that zach
you know what that's an interesting
argument she puts forward uh zach you're
a rebuttal
look at me
if you put on yourself you look like a
clown all right
wallina is ruthless dude
no she kids there's no evidence for her
being joker brand
i don't need to provide evidence i'm not
saying i'm joker brained yeah right are
we not always hold on do we not have a
camera on lena uh we had to sacrifice
one for uh our segment later come sit
over here yeah come on come on down lena
this is too important i think come on
i don't know by the way this i've got
this um
gamer
mango so good
lena get in here
zach came in here stunting on you
after
i mean look
look on friday there was a stunning
upset lena was nominated to be joker
brained we're obviously planning on
having a joker brain off between the two
of you but i mean zach really is coming
out swinging here
and um
i'm just not sure how you feel about
that
he really wants this title
i mean
i hate to take it from him but it's just
what the people want yeah they don't
want that
well they said it though well actually
we voted what more could we do
i will say not obeying the democratic
process is very joker
why don't we just have two jokers then
the democratically elected joker lena
and the uh rogue jokers no that's okay i
want zach to have it he he really wants
the joker you could be at zach
yeah there are a lot of versions of the
jacker i mean the jack jacker and a
jacker the joker i mean lena could be um
you know like one of the cool ones like
from the recent like the walking dead
i just don't want to step on zach's toes
and then he could be like the caesar
romano one no yeah like the goofy 60s
one all right well hang on guys hang on
because we we did debate this a lot on
friday but i just want to say we did run
a poll
8 000 votes in quite a it's a good
sample size 66 lina your thoughts uh
zach
on friday no right now no that's just
happened right now dude
i don't see that data that literally
that's a that's a live poll
one minute ago i'm starting to think
lena is joker brain this is part of her
plan to say she doesn't care about it
but but the joker shouldn't care zach
cares too much
you can't be joker and care that much
about being joker but what evidence is
lena joker brain oh my god it's
everything how
the chip that's not joker bring pain is
not part of joker
that is a good argument loki that's not
a good argument the joker was created
his like the lore of joker he was like
burned in a vat of acid that's how the
joker was born what do you mean pain's
not part of joke he doesn't do good with
pain that's not his thing there's not a
trait of the joker
is that why he carved the [ __ ] smile
on his face he didn't do that his dad
did that that's unknown that's not a
known lord that that's not yeah that's
that's unconfirmed that is not cannon
that's not cannon anyway i mean that's
not cannon have you ever seen the dark
knight yes he have you
every time bro okay but that's one of
the stories dude sure but the point is
is that you don't know what the real one
is so you saying it definitively like
that means that you don't really
understand the lord not good well that's
joker in itself dan
all right all right guys we got to wrap
this up we can't talk dedicate the whole
show to who's joker i've never planned
that i never planned for this whole
thing i just want to say that really
quickly
so zach i mean it's it's all yours you
really want this and
go for it i still maintain that lena's
bane brain because she's the strongest
among us all and she's wearing a mask
today i was literally i have the bane
wikipedia page open right now because i
was trying to remind myself doesn't he
have some like high pain tolerance as a
thing that's his whole thing yeah she is
messed up all right thank you um
thank you thank you
uh zach unfortunately uh you're way down
on the pole here but apparently we don't
care about the democratic process all
the time i don't anarchy shall rise
again my friend
i'm joker um
it's all yours zach
all right well that was a little bit of
a side uh side aside there but okay
uh congratulations zach um
thank you that was great why did you
show up dressed as joker today though
uh i mean you know
why not it's better than the last time
he did remember when he just wore a suit
and you asked why you were in a suit and
he's like oh
ian and dan were saying i should come in
one day as the joker and i was like all
right [ __ ] it but he was just wearing a
suit um what i don't i actually don't
remember oh i would love [ __ ] you
talking about i would love to remind you
guys i'm glad you asked here let me find
it
wow a lot of a lot of uh maybe he's more
friction maybe he's more upset about
this i don't think he wants me to have
nice things
no but i want you to have
everything
let's move on you can go ahead and find
that clip but we have a lot to get to
today thank you zach uh the joker does
make grand entrances so i'll give you
that thank you
i certainly uh prefer joker to be on
time next time you know if
we can do that if we can gotham's trains
run on time okay but the joker doesn't
these henchmen that you know
dude just be on time
okay fine
i'm just kidding he wasn't he wasn't
late he wasn't late i just wanna we're
not doing schtick
we're doing schtick
okay abe dug this up real fast i'm sorry
to be putting you under the gun like
this sec but
this is what they put forward so let's
see we just have uh one from measured
i'm sorry i'm not sure the currency but
it says greetings from belgium really
enjoy the podcast i would probably guess
that it's currency from belgium do i
need a timestamp no this is important
content it leads right into it don't
they use euros there yeah
i have euros
you couldn't tell it was a europa does
this have to do with joker
okay let's just get through this
this is this joker thing not the top of
the show
can we move on ethan this is a wrap
now we're invested let's just see where
this is going [ __ ] baby
i've never bought anything from overseas
to this day the only people that ever
bought wikifeed hats
true and actually apparently the website
was shut down i heard
is it still as of yesterday why the [ __ ]
they're bad
god dude oh thank god thank god they're
working on a new ui for the site
yeah that's good that's good we need to
update it we need to upgrade the servers
i've never bought anything from overseas
i mean not that wasn't in u.s dollars
how is this related how could this
possibly be related
he came in that day wearing a suit you
guys are talking up on me right there
after you were making fun of me and then
i said take that suit off zach take that
suit off bro and i and then someone
asked why are you wearing a suit and
then i said i have a theory for why he
wore a suit it's because you called me
the heartthrob on the previous episode
and he says no i wore it because i was
going to be the joker on friday this is
me as the joker
what england like no that's a pound but
that's not they don't use yours
take that shoot off bro
no you come at me bro
you know i'll come at you i got a theory
as to why you're actually wearing that
suit oh okay why is that oh what is that
because because the comment ethan made
on the last episode
we can move on we can move on maybe you
really wanted me to watch this because
it's about you being the hardship right
it's so obvious
because i'm joker brain wait but it's
still why did you make me watch this tv
holy [ __ ] it's just you talk all right
zach come on
i mean come on do i like someone to plan
zack when you laugh like that i don't
feel funny i feel like don't please this
is all too much for me this joker arc
it's really disrupting the show guys
too tired for this [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah yeah
all right thank you a.b thank you zack
no problem
anyway
how was uh everyone dan you're at the
wedding welcome back thank you thank you
had a good time i had a great time
uh i had a good time
watching the show on friday uh i think
we mentioned this before
uh i left but that was the first episode
since i started working for you that i
have missed
you're a good man it was uh
surreal to watch it just as a viewer i
think we all enjoyed the you hacking in
via your mobile phone did you fix some
tech issues
i mean did you really miss it you were
there in spirit uh well i watched a
decent amount of it in the car um it was
a long trip up to up to big sur so uh
and i wasn't driving so i was just
watching on my phone
do you have any notes for us uh having
watched it as an audience member
um
make sure
that you have a
technical producer there
right at all times right right right and
honestly whoever is generally
responsible for the tech and making sure
that the technical aspects of the show
goes smoothly right
pay them well okay give them a raise
okay all right great good advice thank
you dad
also a b coming in baby faced everybody
i'm sure noticed what's going on here a
little bit of a shave yeah i tried to
line up my beard and then i looked like
dr strange and i tried to fix that and
it led to this and i hate it because i
look 14.
it looks nice it's nice to shave your
beard every once in a while if you like
see what's going on under there you know
it feels nice i feel like i look
grotesque but what do you think lina
i don't like it as much as when he has a
beard but this is cute also
you gotta love when um
sometimes when i shave my beard it's
like
back i can back demon like the girl your
your significant other can't even like
pretend like you look good you know yeah
she's joker brained back demon
yeah
off um
so here we have a lot of stuff at the
top of the show before we get to the
alpha olympics where i prove once and
for all
watching that i am an alpha male i will
win you guys back you understand me
tater tots i will win you back and prove
myself to you
so that's coming up
now dad obviously he made an apology
video so dad built a chair
this was covered on wednesday or friday
i don't remember i'm sorry about your
dad passing away
[ __ ] yeah yeah
thanks bro
he sent us like a unmade chair uh with a
bunch of parts and asked us to assemble
it i mean the whole thing was a joke so
apparently he's feeling bad and dad made
us an apology video so here it is
[Music]
hello ethan
hollow h3
[Music]
when did you get that [ __ ] craziness
mustache that thing is
that thing is insane
it wraps around his nose
it's an intense stash
holy [ __ ] yeah
i'm mortified depressed and ashamed it's
me i can't believe how things turned out
i only wanted to do something nice
but again
i screwed up as usual
i won't make any excuses
i should have assembled the chair like a
good dad like ethan a real dad hard
working laborer
even though my wife left me months ago
it's no excuse even though i'm in the
middle of moving because i can't afford
to live in this facility anymore and i
have to sleep on the floor with my only
companion this elderly orphaned dog
that's no excuse i chose the laser by
sending you this insulting chore to
complete my boxing training for creator
clash 2 has begun and it's hindering my
loyalty to the h3 family i truly love
you all and the show wow you've done so
much for me and during my years of
entertainment smiles and motivation to
keep going i've watched for so long i
even guys voiceover dad use your uh what
the [ __ ] bro
why is this all voiced over
he's already training for his uh creator
clash fight
why did you unmatch me god help whoever
he's up against with h3 i wear my teddy
fresh fanny pack every day loaded with
what he had gamer sup [ __ ] he's
supposing yeah he he's a good man
that is a good man i'll be honest he is
my gamer subs with code h3
oh he even got the waifu [ __ ] dude my
man shout out to code all right all is
forgiving yeah yeah yeah yeah
sup sup sup i wear my teddy fresh fanny
pack every day love you loaded with
backup game reception
hello
i haven't been able to continue my
hellofresh subscription with code h3
because my youtube views are so low i
can't afford it but i'll try to do
better i genuinely cried when i heard
dan and ethan say i was jealous of
supermega and their insensitive atrocity
who would be jealous of that massive
pile of incompetence and lack of
craftsmanship super mega are nothing
more than four chan trolls all right
thank you dad
[Applause]
i only intended to send you the chair
you deserve one fit for a skinny king on
a successful weight loss journey if you
don't mind waiting two weeks for me to
move back to el angelus
he's laying on a little thick with the
it's
very thick you know he's a fan he use
her it's a lot it's a lot we'll come
there and assemble the chair myself
think if you don't want me on the
premises i understand i apologize for
thinking it might have been a fun
project for you all to work on together
bro it's not stupid
as a dad i love putting furniture
together but i'm stupid and i've learned
that please accept my apology no matter
what i will always be a fan i'm sorry
again ethan ela dan a.b zach ian sam
lina love and olivia goodbye yeah okay
now yeah yeah i was waiting for him to
miss somebody and again now i got beef
with that dad
he didn't mention you cam no he did not
mention cam man that's [ __ ] up yep
[ __ ] you dad what an [ __ ] you know
it's like you yeah he worked yeah
he's right cam dry i mean on top of
sending us a chore to do i don't care
how nice his [ __ ] video is
okay now i gotta watch his video
it turned into a whole thing now it's
all about dad just send me the [ __ ]
chair bro
i think that's very sweet dad [ __ ] you
dad
cam's right
dad if you want to make it up i don't
want any more videos i don't want you
coming here and bumming around all day
with your [ __ ] saw and hammer just
send me the damn chair that's what mega
awesome did they sent me a [ __ ] chair
okay now it's the dad show
dad's in chat what's he saying for
himself super mega by the way awesome
super awesome no there's no awesome
right with tits mcgee
your good friends over at super awesome
with tits mcgee yeah dad come on bro
yeah i'm so sorry cam you're killing me
i'm just kidding i love you dad so wait
was that a leak that dad confirmed he's
fighting already
in the crater clash
uh yeah i think he leaked that he's
gonna be in it
i don't know if he mentioned it prior
but
dad i love dad i love dad watching him i
love watching him fight am i having an
aneurysm today
my brain is just off man
you got to get more gamers up to me yeah
sup it up
wanna go throw on the joker makeup with
me
nah
is that gonna wait is that a wake me up
oh dude that is
[Laughter]
that's a good time
i'll pass thanks bro
um post malone eight [ __ ] dude
friend of the show obviously and uh good
friend
we have a kind of like a fetish for
watching creators eat [ __ ] on stage and
actually i feel horrible because
the worst one i've seen the most injured
i've seen someone get is friends of the
show post malone
i mean it was brutal you know when it
was set in the chat i mentally prepared
myself i was like we know pose i really
like post he's a great guy but this is
i'm still excited to see this because
it's funny to see people fall off stages
i know this is the first one that i've
seen and it's not just because i know
him that i was like oh that's not funny
at all [ __ ] horrible i thought he i i
thought he was seriously injured it
looks so bad no he's like writhing on
the floor for such a long time yikes i i
feel like in a way we're responsible for
this because we are such fans of
watching people fall off stage oh it's
back we may have willed this into
existence i'm just so sorry to him
by the way dad says he spent 300 on that
stuff and he needs it back to build it
but we'll put it we'll put it in a box
at the at the curb
now we got to pay shipping the shipping
back to dad and we got to carry it out
it's like so much work
damn all right here's post malone
oh yeah we have to turn this audio off
obviously
but as you can see
extremely extremely hurt
i think what happened was
there's like a big-ass hole in the stage
where they bring out a guitar for him
to play a song
but they forgot to close the [ __ ]
hole
i mean i've seen artists get hurt this
way before they just falling in holes in
stage can we can we figure this out
people
uh so it said in a in a tmz article um
that he had
not laid the blame on the stage crew or
anything apparently he's a good guy
um yeah potentially he made it sound
like he just straight up forgot that at
that part at that point the hole was
supposed to open dude there's no way
that someone wasn't supposed to close
that it's a tiny ass stage right he's
trying to entertain i don't know tens of
thousands of people right there's no
[ __ ] way yeah maybe maybe he's just
trying to not throw anybody he's just
being a yeah he's just being a good guy
and he is a good guy yeah
it's for sure not his fault though oh
god if that was me i'd be like i want
heads bro
i want heads i want names i want
extended family members names i want a
dress that's gotta just
crack some ribs man i think he might
have broken a rib yeah some articles are
saying he did actually he cracked three
ribs whoa
gotta have them ribs
thanks obama oh what else obama
[ __ ] too no thank you
actually and post is such a guy he almo
he continued the show almost finished it
had to leave a little bit early
with three crap drip crap cracked ribs
so i had initially heard that it was
correct but uh i thought i'd i thought
he said uh after visiting the hospital
it was just bruised he didn't break any
he didn't say that
uh but we'll get to it he said i think
he said i'm fine which is kind of
cryptic
but here's another angle
[ __ ] dude that's like the most pain
you've ever been in look at that
in front of 20 000 people or whatever
i think it knocked a breath out of them
too which is
anybody's had that oh that was not a
good feeling
dude that was the worst one we've ever
seen yeah
i know these guys his bodyguards
friends of the show
wow you're so cool man yeah i know him i
know that guy
wow where are you what's his name
i wouldn't tell you
austin post
no not
oh
him
bodyguards that you're so tight with
what are their names i'm not telling you
it's a privacy issue
yeah man
do you think he's embarrassed or i think
he's in too much pain to even feel
embarrassed
oh no yeah i don't think he's thinking
about anything but how much that hurts
in that moment everybody's watching him
and then um
he made a tick talk about the fall so i
think that's what you're referring to
dan
hey st louis
um bucking love you guys so much
um
thank you for the patience um
thank you for putting up with uh my
dumbass there was a
a big uh
so whenever we do the acoustic part of
the show
uh the guitars on the guitar stand and
it goes down
[Music]
and um
there's this big [ __ ] so i go around
there and turn the corner and bust my
ass and
um
winning me pretty good got me
pretty good and
we just got back from the hospital
um
and everything's good everything's good
they gave me some some pain meds and
everything so and we can keep kicking
ass on the tour i just want to apologize
uh to everyone in st louis and i want to
say thank you guys so much for coming
the show and next time i'm around this
way
um we're going to do a two-hour show for
you so we can make up for um
the couple missed songs that we missed
and um
thank you guys for your support and
thank you for your love and and thanks
for hanging around um
uh even though i got my ass kicked by
myself so um i love you guys so much
um
thank you man
have a great night thank you yeah he
seems kind of [ __ ] up i feel like he
must have got some serious damage if
they give him pain meds and stuff
also
are shows usually less than two hours i
mean i never go to concerts yeah yeah
really a set i mean a two-hour set is a
that's a long set i mean some bands do
do that but you know they're the
exceptions uh probably an hour to an
hour 15 minutes an hour i mean you go
out you spend money you do this whole
[ __ ] thing for an hour that's just
the headliner i mean most shows have
openers too so there'll be a couple
right other artists playing i usually i
usually play about two hours that's
usually like an animal you're a rock god
baby
why do you think that other artists
can't hang for a full two hours zach
[ __ ] yeah that's what i was that's
what i
yeah that's gotta be it well
not to take anything away that is
impressive that you play two hours but
uh when a musician is uh touring you
know they're often doing back to back to
back to shows and putting that strain on
your voice especially if you're singer
in particular
that is very true all the time doing
two-hour sets
night after night um
yeah that's that's hard to keep up i've
seen a lot of people say one and a half
hours
um yeah when we saw him at the greek
we saw him doing um
i've never seen this before he was doing
this crazy
steam therapy to like prepare his voice
so i think he does ha it is hard to
maintain yeah the weekend um just had to
stop a show like two songs in because he
lost his voice from going
for so long he did so many shows and he
was playing sofi and he's like i'm i'm
sorry i got to stop holy [ __ ] yeah
um
um
here he is
uh the night before the incident
oh the same show
it's the night after yeah
oh oh so he did another show the next
day yeah oh that's cool
i see and it's closed this time
and he's flicking it off yeah yeah we're
planning a live show it'd be kind of
epic if i had a stage fall
[Laughter]
and it's like a pretty good viral moment
good lord everybody's love input as long
as you shout good lord as you're lord
i wonder if we could fake a stage fall
and have like a cushion down there and i
just
we'll talk about it there's some
possibilities actually yes have we
talked about this public yet uh well
we've mentioned that we were talking
about doing it uh it's not official
official yet but it is getting close
there may be let's just say there might
be more information next week we're
planning our last show of the year is
going to be a live one here in l.a
and i'm going to fall off the stage and
get grievously injured
and hopefully have a viral knife
we'll do it live but there you have it
postman alone
we all wish you well here in the flip
soldier army
you know
and uh god speed to you
cam what what is this can you explain
this someone's found you on amazon uh
yeah i'm cringing at it uh so my friend
jesus christ uh
so my friend chris neal bent over
was his name neil no my friend christina
sent me
a toy as a joke and then she asked me to
take photos with it and then
being a whimsical showman they took all
these goofy like infantilized like soy
type photos
not realizing she was gonna upload them
as the review oh that's awesome and
here's the toy
that's kind of incredible that someone
found these yeah i get it's pretty
interesting
if you if you see the third image that
has the whole review there um i think
that's the second one
cam is loving this toy
good ratings from him
yeah here it is perfect for that unique
friend
you're her unique friend yeah i guess so
so quirky move over ryan's toy review
here's cam's toy review gifted this to
my unique friend who absolutely loves
gorillas as a way to entertain him
jesus it's making you sound like special
needs
he clearly loves it he says quote wow
it's very stretchy and satisfying to
stretch and i stand by both those
statements but uh you know i wouldn't
give it five stars i'll give it four
stars because the head i don't know if
you can hear this
yeah i had it he always has it here he
always has it i could confirm when he
first started he's like you gotta play
with this thing it's awesome it is very
fun to play with how's that a four-star
you've been carrying it around with you
that seems like a five-star the head
itself is not stretchy it's plastic oh
that's that is just what he's like yeah
i see him is she he's a tough critic
you know you gotta be you gotta critique
it uh but yeah is this a fraudulent
review did she fill this out for you um
i think she's projecting that i thought
it was a five-star but it's actually a
four-star gorilla okay well we're gonna
need to report that's frog
yeah yeah shout out to christina who's
that she used to run um lena can you
contact amazon about this fraud review
because it's it's a big problem on the
marketplace my friends sure well
christina used to do
a segment called tina's toy time on the
adult swim streams and this was a call
back to that gotcha well there you go
cameron a prolific amazon uh reviewer
god i cringed so hard when i saw that
i was like i just pretty interesting
when was this review posted this was a
few months before i moved here okay
march yeah
well
there it is guys cameron ladies and
gentlemen
very premium
nope not at all we love it
okay now this is a treat before you uh
move on to that we are at the 32 minute
thank you let's take so after this i
know you guys don't want to hear about
jimmy lee but this is so good he got an
official diagnosis
right psychiatric evaluation very
official and the doctor even made a
video for us and this is a real doctor i
have confirmed
their identity he's a real doctor really
yeah no we got a link to his
instagram that's not that official can
we find like yeah i don't know about
that well let's debate it it says he's a
resident
physician psychiatry uh
uh can you try you could be able to find
his credentials online uh without giving
out his name maybe
but uh while you do that thank you to
honey
yes
everybody loves honey
and they are sponsoring today's uh video
the easy way to save when you're
shopping on your iphone or computer
honey's out of control it's free money
it's always saving me money
it's a free extension
that runs seamlessly in the background
as you shop
and when you get to the checkout
automatically applies the best coupon
on the internet you don't have to think
about it dude
you don't even have to think about it
dude
it's incredible i mean
this one is uh from
something else you lose a shot
women be shopping and heal is no
exception
so true dude
women be shopping yo
uh
graf wants but yeah she's always buying
furniture or
rugs or clothing or we even got it on
postmates which blew my tits right off
of me
right off of you oh you skipped it i saw
it uh
dude 65 bucks off post wow
wait no no 12 bucks off post wait and i
just remembered just the other day we
got this one from a fan
some work shoes yep
it's so easy it's it's really
a no-brainer you don't have to think
about it imagine you're shopping at one
of your favorite sites and when you
click check out the honey button appears
and all you have to do is click apply
coupon boom magic price drops
i'm talking about tech clothing pizza
it works on almost every
major retailer
and it doesn't just work on the desktop
now it also works on your iphone
just activate it on safari
on your phone and save on the go
if you don't already have money you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself
assault and supporting the show so thank
you very much i use honey i love honey
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
h3
tv
thank you to honey
yeah he's a new doctor this gentleman
just uh he's a new doctor yeah he's been
in doc practicing for a year he's still
training but he's a real doctor he's a
trainee i'm not sure exactly oh he
doesn't have his degree he doesn't have
his full certification
i
because i saw this video like that does
not seem like a real doctor yeah
especially a psychiatrist because there
is a there's a level of uh
confidentiality that i think
right how could he just like just i
don't know if it made any sense i don't
know i think jimmy is [ __ ] with us
well
it could be he is on a podcast uh
speaking uh on different psychological
issues can we get a hold of him
yeah i want to know how jimmy found this
guy
yeah
jimmy's in town and he desperately wants
to come i'm not going to talk to him i'm
going to talk to this guy yeah about him
i think i think the the dude follows us
he does he
i i'm messaging him right now do you
want him
wait he you want to talk to him you said
yeah can we get him right right now call
in right now let me ask hell yeah
i would love to know how this connection
happened
yeah but anyway that'll come right after
stamps which we love
if you're a small business owner you
know how important it is to be ready for
the insane holiday season
and if you haven't already started
preparing for the chaos
you're already falling behind luckily
stamps.com has everything you need to
make your life a whole lot easier to 24
7 post office that you can access from
anywhere
no lines no traffic no hassle
stamps is such a good service that if
you mail anything at all
no matter the quantity you're kind of
insane not to use this
it's a one-stop shop for all shipping
and mailing needs
they serve over a million businesses
get access to usps and ups services
right from your computer
and you get deep massive discounts
through stamps
ups and you you sps and ups rates you
get up to 86 percent off
can they do that i i think it's just
because they get so much bulk they
negotiate like insane rates wow yeah
um
use stamp.com to print postage wherever
you do business all you need is a
computer and a printer
and uh here's the best part you print it
you put it on
tape it on and then come pick it up for
me either your front door
or your mailbox you don't have to go to
the post office anymore
it's unbelievable man
if you're running an online store
stamps.com works seamlessly with all the
major shopping carts and marketplaces
and uh since rates are constantly
changing these days
stamps.com switch and save feature you
can easily compare carriers and rates so
you know that you're actually getting
the best deal
um
yeah we talk about how uh dan's
girlfriend ally uses stamps.com for her
her small business she does
and uh
well she loves it it's super easy she
takes care of everything just from home
postman comes and picks it up uh or you
can just drop it off at any post office
or one of those things on the side of
the road and uh
that's it it's that simple yeah i mean
it i love it so much uh get ahead
this whole of the holiday chaos and get
started with stamps.com today sign up at
stamps.com
stamps.com h3tv for a special offer that
includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale there's no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com
h3tv thank you to stamps
thank you
thank you stamps all
sorry to bring the vibes down but i
really need to spread this message so my
roommate crashed his motorcycle essay
and died um
all right well thanks for watching
everybody
tell your friends you love them please
drive safe you could only crash at 100
miles per hour once he was just 24. that
is sad i was very sad head down head
down prayers up for your buddy and sorry
for your loss uh for me it's it's cars
are dangerous people don't appreciate it
because you're in the car all the time
you kind of go into bot mode when you're
driving it that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
dangerous
so keep your head on straight because if
y'all out there dying we're losing subs
every day you think that's going to
[ __ ] help me you guys out there dying
it's just not going to help it was a
motorcycle
motorcycles cars whatever yeah
hello we need you guys healthy
okay because i'm not getting any news
fans i need you guys to watch well we're
working on that today we're turning the
tater tots around
yeah hello
hello
hello
can i
say that that often the soundbites
oftentimes infect all of our brains
i don't know what it is about that
[ __ ] hello hello i can't help i can't
stop i can't stop saying hello
hello
i took a call yesterday and i found
myself i said it exactly like he didn't
think
and i was thinking about the whole call
i couldn't hello i was like hello hello
hello hello hello
hello
hello
hello so we can afford uh speaking of
ninja yo check this out
attention all fortnight players in the
audience
fortnite
has been sending out surveys
because they're i guess they're trying
to do some market research about who
they want to work with in the future
and on the survey
is none other
than h3h4 tonight
gerber x fortnight like
i love that what are we gonna do a kaya
gerber collab that's like cindy
crawford's daughter
yo we got a really vibrant fortnite
community here we got the gamer sup
mango flavor
sam is basically ninja's protege if we
don't get his sam skin by the end of the
year i'm [ __ ] pissed oh man now that
would be epic i would absolutely die
we need a sam skin
yes so pretty exciting um up against
huge huge uh other competitors like uh
the stokes twins
dixie dimelio's on there angry birds
characters
trinity trinity from the matrix sorry
okay i don't know if you all heard them
from lord of the rings
eminem characters
nemo peter griffin what year is it wait
nemo conan the barbarian that would be
dope how would that even work it's a
fish
wait who nemo yeah
uh does that have a very could work that
make it work yeah fortnite's wild like
that yeah
meta no one has legs okay
right but it's kind of cool that i'm on
here even
mm-hmm with the likes of
now you have to start playing fortnite
yeah i don't know why i'm trying to
fortnite
but you have to play
you know
listening to um
that sound bite of will smith it is
incredible the staying power of fortnite
they're they're pretty pretty
for tonight that was like pretty
incredible 2018 2018 yeah yeah no it's
they're incredible i'm telling you guys
they're smart
they know how to run a video game over
there
yeah so vote for me as your next
fortnight skin
i got moved
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
it's only a dance because they put it in
no it's ninja's dance whenever we get a
hello it's not a good dance and i'm
sorry ninja it's just not ethan klein
boys over there the crew
[Music]
we think the dance is iconic
i'm just saying i have better moves vote
for me ethan klein thank you for the
five dollar dono
think of it
yes so if you guys if you guys get this
survey in your mail
check it out you know what to do
here's another great moment that
happened over the weekend
some dude
randomly posted on this subreddit
he just said ban me
mods please ban me from this sub i hate
h3
i'm not subscribed
and reddit won't stop showing me the sub
and i don't see any way to block it
please ban me
uh it now has
7135 points
i actually i think we should make them a
mod without any authority just like an
honorary mom yeah can we do that right
now when i add him uh i can try i think
they might have to accept it though so
they might oh [ __ ] they might not go for
it yeah uh i'll see what i can we're
gonna mod you bro
i think it's only fitting i'm so happy
this went up because uh if you scroll
down you'll see that i actually replied
to this and i i just happened to uh i
was still on the road driving back from
the the wedding and just opened up the
subreddit and i saw this post with i
think at the time about a hundred
upvotes or something
and i just thought it was so [ __ ]
funny that i had to reply to him
i said nah yeah i'm not banning you i'm
not banning you
it's on your homepage bro that's great
for me
of course a lot of the uh sentiment was
that he's just one of us which is true
you know we hate h3 we're not subscribed
right and we're on the subject we're on
the subreddit yeah this is exactly where
you belong
hundred subs yes
so uh welcome everybody our new mod
reinaco
look through his post history
yeah i'm not i didn't even know that if
you weren't subscribed you could even
see posts from our subreddit i don't
think you can i don't think you can
either i'll be totally honest i think he
might have accidentally subbed at some
point or something because um i don't
think we show up in
in the uh
there's are popular in our all
which will show you you know big posts
from subreddits that you aren't
subscribed to and i believe we're
blacklisted from both of those we are we
are i know we are
i remember when they changed the
algorithm there was a point when
anything would show on the homepage and
people were getting annoyed by a bunch
of [ __ ] they didn't care about so they
started
restricting subreddits like ours yeah
with a very niche
community so they don't show up on the
homepage but this guy's definitely like
a uh
tater tot slash rogan head because all
this posts are about mma and [ __ ] so
this is this is the real deal people are
saying they now do suggested posts which
is different than
all and popular and i guess that that
that is uh
yeah people are saying recommended
it's all mma yeah we're getting
recommended
well maybe he'll
like you after today because we're gonna
alpha the [ __ ] out of it if we can
convert him
because that's the goal today if we can
convert
we can convert anybody
right
also his other post about bitcoin where
can i buy bitcoin and then transfer it
out immediately interesting or do you
happen to be working with steak
anyway uh did were you able to send that
mod invite i'm working on that right now
yeah
please check your uh
he's definitely gonna see that's so
awesome dude i hope he accepts
um
jordan peterson also speaking of uh red
pilled alpha chads
l-m-f-a-o uh joker-brained peterson took
to the stage
last week to do a comedy set as you know
when i think jordan peterson i think
hilarious funny guy
he's a funny guy he's the man has a way
with making people laugh unleashed
i don't think of like a teary-eyed
crying all the time yeah uh depressed
sorry not eating
slowly dying
wonderful to welcome jordan peterson to
our show tonight at comedy unleashed
finally
free
let's unleash this comic
oh [ __ ] become the joker literally bro
this is mad joker contour oh
so true
yeah so um here's a clip of him going on
stage
but somehow this set is gone it's just
so interesting if anybody has the set
i'm dying to see it
great night at comedy unleashed
i love that they're unleashing comedy
finally finally it's been held back too
long
i haven't laughed in months years
every budding beauty
god i hate that clip it's unleashed
and with that in mind we've got some
guys coming we need to leash up the
trans and unleash the comedy
feelings
would you please welcome jordan peterson
this is a comedy club right
[Applause]
standing oh
standing oh
he just crushed he's gonna crush that
room bro
he's just crushing it the fact that this
man gets a standing ovation
is just so [ __ ] wild
[Applause]
[Music]
easy crowd i wouldn't exactly call this
a set
man if only i had a crowd like that
he then proceeded to just ramble about
the fall of western civilization for the
next two hours
and then she said to me i was born a man
and i said
then you're a man dammit
trans people am i right
oh
where would we be without comedy clubs
they've leashed up comedy all over the
country
all right rynko has been invited as a no
permissions mod and honorary mod thank
you man to the subreddit so we'll we'll
see if he accepts i'm so excited for
that
um he says the show describes itself as
the home of free thinking comedy
and comedians who leave self-censoring
button leave the self-censoring button
at the door
finally lol stand-up comedians who think
outside the group think bubble and make
us laugh fine it sounds so funny this
sounds like it's such a funny set of
people dude i just oh that's so awesome
bro tell me tell more transphobic
basically they're like we're just gonna
tell a bunch of trans jokes all night
so just a dave chappelle set basically
yeah
pride according to one audience member
jordan was reading a poem from his phone
[Laughter]
unleash that comedy jordan oh i'm being
told uh a two dollar donation from
anthony hey king tick tock banned you
again rip
those tater tots man they're they are
relentless
but if i i so far if i appeal it
[ __ ] yes it works every time
is it true this is just a random donut
definitely true live access suspended
so
nice um let's appeal i mean
misinformation yeah they misinformation
they i just get reported for tons of
[ __ ] the last time was harassment this
time they said we do not allow content
that spreads misinformation
uh okay appeal
shut up
thank you
shout out to all my the tick tock uh
tater tots out there good people that
was the game we were targeting today
that's the whole point of this episode
right well they'll find it they'll find
it
yeah so here is comedy unleashed here's
the great man in action reading a poem
from his phone now this isn't ironic
somehow
this is a comedy unleashed ladies and
gentlemen
maybe
maybe it is like some real like
you know hyper ironic like some andy
kaufman kind of [ __ ] he just goes up
there and just dryly reads poetry for
two hours
why do i why do the trans people offend
me so
is it because
is it because
i love men
i don't know anyway
they said do you have a recording
someone said they'll probably put on
youtube soon have we checked youtube for
comedy unleashed
let's check it out
let me check again delete yeah
well i want to unleash this set
can't handle jordan set being chained up
like that
thank you anthony hey king tick tock
banjo again thank you yeah we got that
i don't see
damn
jordan dying for that [ __ ] man
they got some big names on here though
really pull it up yeah
i've i've been refreshing this rosie
will be
the legendary rosie wilby
uh we have isa bonacera you know her
right huge fan of her work unchained man
she just speaks her mind and i love that
jonathan cogan you can't you can't stop
jonathan cogan what i love about donovan
is that he doesn't hold back yeah no
he's on jane he's unleashed
he's free
oh tobias my boy well sort by popular
let's see if actually anyone's done this
nicholas is santo
politically incorrect guys let's let's
watch this
check it out yeah let's see
let's see how it changes this
some people are chuckling
looks like some people are not happy
with their ferrari's performances lately
is your lamborghini losing bits and
pieces sir
what's going on here
anyways uh people tell me
what's with that american accent i chose
to learn english with an american accent
because i wanted to sound cool
that was not the funny part why are they
laughing this is like the softest
audience ever dude
i gotta do a set here man i love these
unchained folks
it's like the softest set man
wait i wanted to see a joke you bailed
too fast yeah okay i want to see their
star pupil
my comedy coach told me always open with
your least controversial joke
[Music]
my wife is from south of germany she's
austrian
wow
that's [ __ ] awesome dude
[Music]
with uh with dark historical undertones
germans have the best sense of humor in
the world
skeptical didn't you know that the main
purpose of the european union was to
contain germany's aspirations of
supremacy
you still don't think they don't get
humor
i i must say i'm a right-wing comedian
by the way do you guys like it yes we
love that
idiot he's excited dude he's positive
i love right-wing
people that say i i have this political
affiliation at the top of the show
my meta audience went harder yeah that's
true
that's [ __ ] true that's from chat
very true
yo
he's right wing okay he's unchained
let's hear it
you get things that you get to say
things which are not politically correct
you are essentially correct
right for example maybe
maybe
if you want to go to university you must
pay for it
dude no he didn't just say that this guy
is so unchained right now [ __ ] dude did
he say that
did he say that
holy [ __ ] bro
they let him say that
all right let's keep going man i don't
know what he's gonna say next this is
crazy
not fair to tax the bus driver because
you want a degree in history of art
what is history of art anyway
history of art has anybody ever studied
history of medicine
can you help me with my heart problem
doctor no but let me tell you all about
dr christian barnard
the south african surgeon who carried
out the first ever human to human heart
transplant
yeah
i mean
okay thumbs up a little semantical there
buddy i mean
you're not gonna go to historian for
medical treatment i mean uh let's be
real
wait i [ __ ] love this guy send me the
link down because i get in i'm gonna
need to pause send me at the time stamp
you know what i mean
this guy's crushing man
who's better him or dave rubin
discover usually this guy
yeah this guy you think
i mean dave rubin unironically does not
get laughed
even in the soft even even in this
audience he would be because they
because he's gay they don't like that
yeah they don't care
his friends come to his wedding so yeah
exactly his own friends [ __ ] hate him
it's just common sense maybe islamic
state has something to do with islam
just a little bit i mean it has is let's
[ __ ] go ethnic genocide muslims are
terrorists let's [ __ ] do this i mean
let's go
let's go god he's spitting right now
did he say that
damn
it's not that like
you can't say it it's that
you're it's not really funny or it's not
funny yeah exactly i mean also it's not
even uncommon it's what people said
right thinking and saying for decades
right yeah
but you know i just find so ironic
because the minute you make fun of
christians they [ __ ] the tears the tears
the amount of [ __ ] people can't gave me
because i said the church is just like
basically uh sanctioned to pedophilia
the tears bro
i love this that's great man
yeah uh i don't uh elijah wood is doing
it is crushing it today thank you i saw
that on in uh the chat in its name
if something yeah there's also ah
all right i'm not gonna pick apart his
eh thank you
um this is going better than it did in
camden
look at the [ __ ] hogs in here bro
look at this this you just got back from
a pig calling contest
he plays second place not first he's not
the best but he's pretty good
damn and this dude just grew the biggest
[ __ ] pumpkin in the county
[Laughter]
squeal now
a lot of white people here too eh
yep kind of weird how that happened not
very diverse in there
right
if something were called nazi germany
don't you think it had some elements of
nazism to it
yeah it's the whole country's flu
let's hear him out
i thought he was about to be like yo the
islamic state had some good ideas
because that's kind of what they play
with these days right
yeah it's not that like
what's the first baptist church or
what's the ones that are like protest
people's funerals and [ __ ] uh the
westboro baptist church church
church is in their name [ __ ] owned
all christians
[Laughter]
some of you are thinking this is getting
pretty offensive
my grandfather fought for nazi germany
i'm shocked right on the nose so learn
that right on no
[ __ ] way this man knows his audience
yo that joke [ __ ]
rules how many nazis in the audience
tonight
oh cool me too
dude i love the joke yo they love that
joke too much man
they love that joke too much
let me tell you a bit about myself uh i
graduated in history of art
hey
hey
i graduated in italy
do you know what it means to get a
degree in history of art from the
country that invented history and art
getting a degree in history of art from
italy
is like getting a degree misogyny from
pakistan
it's the highest level
pakistan
invented misogyny i mean it's a country
that ever created in the 1950s
didn't exist before that
that's kind of funny why i don't know
why i singled out like pakistan yeah why
pakistan there's plenty of misogyny in
other places
okay shout out to the pakistanis ladies
and gentlemen
also
italy famously not a misogynistic
culture what is this guy's ethnicity i'm
curious because he said he was german
or austrian or something
oh he is didn't he say that at the
beginning maybe that was just a
geographical joke yeah i thought he was
just a little
geographic comedy there
right but they're a much older muslim
country like there
were many many better options to pick
yeah
yeah
i'm saying he's italian iranian oh okay
yeah okay so he's persian gotcha okay
interesting
do you guys like nation states
yeah give me any country
slovenia can you do more difficult
slovenia is not bad guardian
uzbekistan right
crowd
okay
what did he ask them
any fans of nation states any fans of
nation states out there um
yeah
oh your audience man
[Laughter]
they so know your audience
what was what did uh hitler called the
plan he wanted to take over like all of
russia for like bastard for like
yeah or something like that any any any
countries for some levin's room out here
that means living space a living room
living spaces in slovenia
former soviet republic in central asia
landlocked country the flag has three
horizontal bars uh
green and uh blue and in the middle you
have white white is edged in red and
there's a crescent and 12 stars capital
city is tashkent what on earth was the
point of that bit
the point of that bit was not to impress
the ladies
the point of that bit was to show you
that brexiteers can be cosmopolitan and
knowledgeable
thank you
he's a brexiteer
that's yeah
oh my god
this guy is [ __ ] this guy is funny
holy [ __ ] yeah i thought i could tell
you why this is the top rated
video on this channel
this comment says i thought this sort of
comedy was illegal in the western world
yup
[ __ ]
so refreshing to see comedians at this
club who remove the veneer of [ __ ]
that is foisted upon interactions
and create real laughter
that's awesome
yeah the comedians are the real uh
victims here society
so
um 50 shades of grey is the
i don't have time for segways
i know you want your brakes um listen uh
segway is an italian word by the way
that's right this is the most watched
part so i'm just gonna skip ahead
this is apparent when he tears the
[ __ ]
crowd down let's see i assure you none
of them none of them had
cat ears
of course
strong independent women hate donald
trump because his policies mean that
they will ultimately have to pay for
birth control and if there's anything a
strong independent woman really hates is
to pay for her own stuff
dude i [ __ ] love right wing comedy
it's so awesome at least that one like
that was an offensive joke or whatever
but at least that like that was maybe
the first like joke
that i've heard this entity by the way
we've spotted the lib [ __ ] i guess it
was the uh
she's not amused
we got the first joke laughter get the
[ __ ] out
[Applause]
speaking of strong women hillary clinton
is still promoting her latest book it's
called what happened
in this book described by new york times
as a feminist manifesto hillary explains
that she lost to trump because american
white women could not resist persuasion
from their male family members so they
went out and voted for trump
you just hate it
when a feminist candidate cannot smash
the glass ceiling because of all these
millions of stupid impressionable women
standing in here
i mean hillary clinton is a [ __ ]
lame-o sap so
i haven't read her book though
[Applause]
yeah somebody said this guy would crush
and gilead
i'm just chilling in cedar rapids
that video is funnier than anything i've
seen in this video women can give
hillary some credit that's a good point
i'm just saying story does suck but that
video is fire
women be shopping i'm glad you got
that joke
because that could go either way
formula one abolished grid girls you
know great girls were models wearing
kind of revealing skimpy clothes on on
the racetrack doing promotional
activities and after formula one
abolished them some of these girls went
on twitter lashed out at feminist they
said we lost our jobs because of you but
i think it's great it's great that
formula one did that because in this day
and age we can no longer allow the
patriarchy to tell women what to do with
their bodies it is up to less attractive
women
[Applause]
any any dual citizens in the room yes
yeah uh okay
people ask me what is the best thing
about having been in solitary
confinement in this lab
in the islamic republic of iran
you know the silver lining and that
stuff um you know the great thing about
having been interrogated by the
notorious iranian intelligence in a dark
cold hostile room is that this thing is
no longer the scariest experience of my
life
all right everybody it's nicholas de
santo yeah comedy unleashed uh
just imagine what the [ __ ] on the bottom
is like holy [ __ ] that's if that's the
top rated [ __ ] holy smokes man
well i'm super happy to welcome jordan
peterson to the ring so that great
organization yeah i can't wait i can't
wait to see his worthless it makes me
happy that so many unfunny people were
able to find each other yeah
yeah they probably felt like really left
out community is important that's so
that's so true
solidarity is everything that's what it
is
so so there's that um we're working
towards the alpha male segment i'm not
looking forward to it because i'm going
to take an ice bath and i'm [ __ ]
putting it off for as long as possible i
do not want to get in that ice
um well
we are uh
closing in on it though so i gotta go to
the bathroom okay
then maybe we'll do the alpha male uh
segment here hell yeah brother
there's a few other stories here like
um
one that i'm really interested in oh
interesting no real quick yeah very
insightful comment someone said it has
views because it got posted on our crin
no
[Music]
yeah let me see if i can reverse search
it that that actually explains a lot
that's the best
let's check it it had a lot of likes
though it had like 29 000 likes yeah and
all the comments were super important
crazy
that's so good
whose grandparents fought for the nazis
here show our hands joanne
um
all right i'm gonna go back i also
wanted to talk about this the twitch
streamer that scammed a bunch of people
oh right no we definitely got to talk
about that so i think we should do that
before
yeah
stuff last cause you are not going to
want to continue the show after um
shredder puked apparently earlier
in the stream and the chat is trying to
let us know oh they saw it what
baby how would they even see that
probably
right there from the instagram went down
oh wow
shredder's been puking a lot feel better
poor guy he always pukes a lot i think
it's like one of the
potential conditions of being a little
yorkie
being inbred
but
i don't know i've been trying a lot to
like they say feed them a snack before
bed
um
there's this enzyme or uh enzymes that
he just won't [ __ ] eat he will not
eat it
so yeah i'm saying it's very common
yeah it's common with yorkies yeah but i
feel bad it's not good for his mouth and
his teeth are getting [ __ ] up
you're so cute look at him and cute the
puking
but
it's not normal actually i was going to
wait till after the show ethan but the
the vet said we should bring him in
if it's been happening often it's not
common that's weird because i took them
to the vet like a year ago and they said
it's normal for this kind of small dog
and they just told me to give him a
snack
before bed and to try to get him to eat
these uh
yeah
i remember
whatever some [ __ ] enzymes but so what
what did you tell the vet lena oh i said
i was gonna double check with you
because they wanted to know if um is he
still behaving normally like yeah he's
totally
yes
everything's normal his behavior is
normal his appetite's normal he's
totally fine and then is the puke like
liquidy or is he throwing up food
uh it's like yellow
stomach bile it has
it's usually just stomach while i love
that we're doing this diagnosis now it's
just yellow stomach well sometimes you
can see here there's just little bits of
stuff but he's not like puking up his
meals you know okay yeah and they said
if it is bile also that's not common for
them so what yeah that's literally the
opposite of what they told me last time
i'll double check because she didn't ask
what breed he is i just gave the name
and because he's been there so many
times i figured maybe they'll pull up
his chart but i'll double check with you
yeah it's you it's it's always just
yellow stomach bile
okay yeah i'll let them know
um i'm gonna go to the bathroom and then
we'll we'll we'll move on so i'll be
right back okay
okay
what the heck
what the heck and dog is right how we
doing everybody out there
beautiful world
let's see we have uh
some member chats coming in we got a
let's go from manual
let's go 17 months a member
wow legend what a g
uh
redders in the chat oh that's like
shredder but with the w
redder's in the chat
saw bert and tom talk about how ethan is
the wrong guy to mess with laughing
emoji uh
facts
i feel a faint uh i feel ashamed to bear
his name oh you have the same last name
as uh
no you're santos this guy's santo you're
good you're good
santa we love the santos
clan here
uh so no stress i have a story real
quick
you got story yeah this weekend i went
to hollywood
and i went to a place called the icons
of darkness museum and i saw something
you might like to see guys
what'd you see hold on let me share it
can you pull stuff up on the discord uh
yeah yeah just send it in discord pull
it up and um the tour guide was matt
who's also a football trooper so shout
out to you matt why is there just a
picture of ethan
is this what you meant to say yeah
they had the
original penguin
costume there and i thought of
yeah that is really cool
i thought of you guys that's awesome not
to say who i thought of but i thought of
you guys
keep it general yeah can i say two
things one
i want to shout out all the fans i met
at universal over the weekend you guys
were awesome it was really cool meeting
a lot of you guys we got flooded there
it was really cool
and
you got like approached by a ton of
people yeah a lot of people
i have family here from out of town so
it made me look good oh very good and
the other thing i want to say is uh zach
lewis live at the troubadour let's
[ __ ] go dude
i went to a karaoke bar this weekend
and it's the coolest place to just sit
down and watch because for some people
it's
you i didn't realize this but the more
that i stayed the longer i realized that
performances were like really important
to some of them like there was a guy who
was i think it was probably his 50
something if birthday and he looked like
a real jock he had a letterman jacket on
he clearly played
football or something and all of his
buddies were with him and they were all
supporting him as he went up and he like
said
i'd love to sing for a really long time
and then he just busted out and he gave
us the most beautiful performance and
then there was a man what was the song
oh it was some country thing okay i
don't know but um there was also a man
in a red leather jacket i took a video
of him but before his performance he
leaned against the wall he had no no one
was there with him it was just him he
leaned against the wall with one of his
legs up just like arms crossed and then
he got started and it was really
really something to see well it was
pretty
fun pretty good
somebody said dan i was also at a
wedding this weekend and we kept joking
we're gonna run into you at the dance
floor um
i i boog it down a little bit i got down
it was an interesting wedding because
the groom
uh is costa rican and his whole family
was there
and the bride was jewish and so it was
it it was like a
both um
latino jewish wedding uh
uh i think that's the fridge open or
something oh oh stop
so you know they did like the horror and
like all that and then you know a bunch
of like
latin music
going back and forth between jewish and
lab music
all right well
let's talk about this twitch streamer
and then i'll [ __ ] god i don't want
to do this ice bath
oh
i have to do it though enthusiastic yeah
improve yourself come on
all right so
this story is real interesting
a lot there's been a lot of twitch drama
lately i don't know if you guys noticed
that like
yeah there was like xqc you had an
argument with his girlfriend our
ex-girlfriend that was freaking out
about
but this one seems downright just crazy
and criminal
uh it started
there's this streamer
called slicker and do you know who this
is love did you know who this was before
of course he's a massive streamer he is
yeah or he's been kind of m.i.a for a
while
i guess since his starter
wow that's interesting so he was at one
point a massive streamer
yes
this situation started
when a user on live stream phil posted a
video
of this guy asking them for money
and this started a chain reaction where
a bunch of people revealed
that this streamer slicker was also
asking them for money
so here is the video
um
i hope you don't hate me on this
it's so cringe and i'm cringe for asking
my brother please do not hate me
please
keep it personal as well
basically um my bank account got locked
this has happened for like three four
days i've been asking around people
sadly
um today well tomorrow is the last day
um until my credit starts getting [ __ ]
up it got locked out and i was looking
for people to actually work and that
could i either i could ask if i could
borrow from and i'll pay back genuinely
give me two months and i can pay back if
you can't know where is my brother if
you can
[Music]
but please um don't feel forced to say
yes
uh yeah i'm sorry i couldn't get in the
call to do this so i'm i feel genuinely
embarrassed i've asked a few streamers
they couldn't help and
yeah i don't mind it it's okay um so i
just went out asked a few subs i've
noticed
and yeah he's asking a fan for money
dude
why don't you just stream he's a big
streamer does he just make money when he
works
you know who wants me to take their
money yeah
so
apparently
he's been reaching out to a bunch of his
viewers on discord asking for money
yo
here he is yo you there yo bro
you couldn't do another 600 legit i will
have you back soon
what here's another one
i sent you 130.
i'll send you 1300 now
love you king no problem yo bro if i ask
for 1.1 k i got you all on my brother
say no if you can't don't worry but
mom's life i got you heading to bank
tomorrow
damn bro i gotta go to bed now work in
the morning
so the i mean this is all just him
hitting up fans for money dude
look at all i didn't realize there was
so much going on here why didn't the guy
just stream he's well he's just
all day scamming people
so
i i just double checked his twitch stats
and he i guess he kind of fell off a
little bit late this year i he dropped
some viewers this year quite a lot so
maybe maybe streaming isn't as of a
solid income for him anymore so it's
like everyone knows who he is but he's
not definitely crazy money he's very
very known on twitch yeah
what was his category of streaming
uh like just shouting and
i think he played some games every now
and
then
don't want to be rude or anything please
do not see this as a disrespect
disrespectful message non-intended
um basically um
my bank account got locked this guy's
running the nigerian prince don't have
access to my money on everyone
because he wants to lose some money it
doesn't really work when you're everyone
knows who you are
that's like a bad way to commit fraud
so the reason i guess
it came out that he's scamming his fans
and he moves on to start scamming fellow
twitch streamers he even scammed the
cancer patient out of the money they
needed for treatment hell no
but man like
you were my friend bro
and
before i was going for my transplant
knowing you're not going to pay me
you're asking for my money but i pulled
together to save my life
and
you had no intention even though i've
already given you money
you never paid backpack and then you
asked for another 10k
before i'm meant to be going to america
to pay for this stuff man i just want to
know
i know addiction
is difficult but
damn
that is [ __ ] up
shout out uh hassan's this apparently
his strong clip so he's all over this
[ __ ] too
we're back this thursday by the way
wow this guy is [ __ ] up yeah so it
came out he's a gambling addict
um
which is interesting of course given
twitch's
cozy relationship with gambling
here's an edit of all the videos he sent
out asking
people for money it has copyrighted
music in it though
or in the beginning it does sorry to
bother you oh this is hassan's editor
who put this together
um i have a problem with myself
should i just skip forward past the
copyrighted music got queen
the whole way
um
okay so that's not gonna work but you
guys get the idea
it's a mash-up of all these edit videos
he sent people
streamers started coming forward asking
about uh
saying that he asked them for money too
names include hassan xqc mischief anika
anita
pokeman minks asman gold and many more
damn
here he is saying that it all started
from you guessed it
cs go gambling
what a surprise
[ __ ]
shout out face clamp it's all it's all
happening right here
face the [ __ ] up dude
um
ever since cs go not to blame but
ever since just to clarify this is him
like coming clean uh love
yeah or yeah this is from two days ago
and is there people who are like oh it's
an addiction let's get him help or is
everyone like [ __ ] this guy to hell
but probably both at the same time i
think i think you can
be uh you can think both at the same
time you know it's it's sad that he's in
that situation but he kind of put
himself in there you know
i mean there's just it's a little
sadistic though to be taking like money
from cancer patients i mean yeah there's
got to be some
there's got to be some
well it's like an illness you know
addiction
all that but you know it's definitely
not all to blame you know definitely not
um
it's the first time i went on that site
and i uh
i was it was it was a fun place to be
you know gamble skins and stuff
and um
uh
wow
eventually i found out you could gamble
with money
i
i started to gamble with money and um
[Music]
this was even when i started having my
first job
and then um
[Music]
whatever
um yeah and uh
going on one streamer says he was
scammed out of 27 000.
train wreck says he gave him a hundred
thousand dollars as a gift what the [ __ ]
you just gave him a hundred thousand
dollars yeah i gave him a lot of money
usd
just a gift like i literally said just
get you know i mean straight gift
and i wasn't happy about it like don't
get me wrong i wasn't like oh you don't
have that and i was like listen like get
your [ __ ] together i'm pissed we're done
though
i mean
that was the trade-off it was like we're
done
i'll be done with you for a hundred
thousand
did train wreck i'm sorry but this guy
is [ __ ]
the amount of money that passes through
this guy's hand from being affiliated
with steak is [ __ ] mentally ill like
i've heard him do this before he's like
here's a hundred thousand dollars for
you here's it's like dude
it's not normal this world you guys are
living in state gives him so much
[ __ ] money
he's just like here's a hundred thousand
to feed your gambling addiction don't
ever talk to me again
i mean
like
it feels dumb and that's a lot of money
it's super generous whatever but
it just feels [ __ ] weird it is weird
yeah it's very strange it's there's no
like
[ __ ] man
yeah but hit uh train i'll hit you up i
got problems
we can not be friends anymore i'll take
the 100k
we got i got problems bro train i got
problems my bank account's all [ __ ] up
can't play my employees just this one
time bro come on
that's insane
uh slicker confirmed that he got a
hundred thousand from train wreck on
stream
um well i didn't i didn't question that
so whatever
and then train wreck of course is coping
hard
of course he gets all of his money from
gambling from steak to be clear
the people scapegoating slots
blackjack and roulette
and not blaming the individual are the
real oh they're the real problem
they're the real [ __ ] problems
this would have never happened without
you guys you're the real problem
the real problem are the people that are
upset
the you guys are you guys did this
the real problem
on top of that slicker was a sports
gambling addict hello
the one type of gambling that is
normalized
and that i don't want to hear a single
one of you clout goblins [ __ ] talk
about
yeah no sports gambling is the problem
not slots i don't see you guys are the
problem also i gave him a hundred
thousand dollars like it was a [ __ ]
like i was just buying him a coffee
that's normal anyway yeah steak paid me
five million dollars this month but you
guys are the problem
what a coping ass [ __ ] bro how much
[ __ ]
you you you can only bare your head in
the sand for so long i don't know this
is [ __ ] insane to me
this man is so deluded
he's never gonna stop either until
either
he's i'll tell you what train wreck at
this rate is going to be the one
scamming people in a few years when the
stake money stops
[ __ ]
this came after um
lots of people were calling
for twitch to ban gambling which a lot
of people have been saying
youtube doesn't allow gambling
which is why steve will do it was banned
pokeman said like if twitch should ban
gambling and of course trainok was she's
the problem
when i jerk off donnie
i might
[Laughter]
dude i'm actually surprised 21 000
people actually like this
i'm
yeah you also make up your mind is it
the individual's fault or is it a
disease you know it's like
he's picking and choosing where
where to put the blame
oh god train wreck
i don't know love i know you're a fan of
these guys i mean this this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] insane right i mean i don't know
yeah yeah he's got tweet it's insane
okay okay good i'm glad because
i don't think you're like a defender of
them but you generally have like a
a fairly for a long time and i really
like them as people but what they're
doing right now is [ __ ] [ __ ] i
think gambling should be banned you know
the like
top of the top argument for everything
is like you get paid right they pay you
for a reason they don't pay you for fun
they pay you because you are making them
profit you know yeah you're fine so i
mean well according to train wreck love
you're the real problem yeah
yeah i am i am this is all your fault
yeah
sorry trey
you know what you know what the problem
is though it's definitely not me
wow
that was [ __ ] on the nose zach
that was on the nose what what is your
what is your hypothesis at this point
for twitch not acting on this
i think it's been well over a year at
this point that it's been like a
phenomenon on twitch i think twitch is
losing
audience they're losing people people so
many other top streamers are going to
youtube
there's more competition
i don't understand twitch bismuth
they're like they'll ban their biggest
streamer dr disrespect who goes to
youtube
and all these people are coming to
youtube i think they literally are
afraid of losing more people
i don't think twitch is long for this
world like i'm i mean they're not going
away anytime soon but i'm talking over
the next 10 years i don't think
they're gonna have this monopoly at
least that they do now and they know
that they're scared
um and it's actually a fairly big
category for them actually yeah no
absolutely so i think that's the only
reason is xuc not the biggest streamer
on the platform still yeah by far i
think
so
oh thank you to slicker for 50 gifted
subs thanks bro whose money was that
hello was that train part of train
wrecks 100k i'll take it
so in in essence that was from stake
stake by the transitive property just
gifted 50 subs i mean i just
i just pulled up i mean correct my wrong
this is this is his account right i mean
seven hours ago yeah he's not banned
they haven't taken oh no yo
and he's literally scamming users and
and colleagues and actually what's
interesting is i feel like he's riding
this wave it's benefiting him people are
watching him they're talking about him
and then the other crazy thing is he
said a gambling company he didn't say
which i'm assuming it's stake said we
will pay off all your gambling debts
if you let us sponsor you now i'm not i
don't know that at stake for sure
but stakes the person that i see
predominantly across twitch so
if someone did reach out to him it's my
assumption that it would be stake
and so um
they're essentially
pro uh gambling addiction
i mean obviously that's how they make
their money and they come out and save
it they're 100
because usually again with regulated
casinos
they have to have a lot of
they have to have ways for you to ban
yourself from a lifetime where you can
say don't ever accept my money again
they have like get help for gambling
addiction all over the place there's
regulations uh basically in place
whereas stake is like i will pay off
your at stake allegedly based on my
assumption
is like um
i will pay off your gambling debt
and allow you to keep doing your
addiction that's [ __ ] crazy ian just
sent this this is this is the clip if
you want to watch it yeah i'm gonna pull
it up right now
okay that makes sense if you've got a
gambling if you go he's chatting with
hassan and
his give miss kiff he's
is this what i'm saying he's not he's
kind of like
embracing it all
it's kind of gross
juicing he's juicing it up
uh slicker said on stream today had he
not got caught he would have continued
it
legend i'll get to that next got a
gaming sponsor tomorrow would you do it
um
i
that's a yes
i mean already yeah
not gonna say who
yes um i just got a call with a casino
they said um they would help me pay off
the people
if i do the sponsor of them but i
refused it i couldn't do it
no
that's why
there's a there's a chance that he's
making it up too
because i mean the guy's
he's a serial liar
because i was like it would just not
make any sense like
[ __ ] mind dude okay um
yeah i love that he's on the apology
tour right now
it's awesome people are watching his
stream again
he's loving it and then the other funny
thing is xqc
who makes a shitload of money from
gambling
sponsorships who
said i'm done it was [ __ ] up i should
have never done it and then a few months
later i was like let's get that
stake money coming
he's like yo i'm gonna pay off all the
debt
using stake money
because i'm like train wreck have
irrational little irrational amounts of
money
from steak isn't that what happened love
so he's like yo i'm gonna pay off
everyone's debt and and but he's still
doing the gambling on his stream right
yeah so she's probably back the money so
he gets to be the good guy
but he's part of this whole [ __ ]
machine actually he's a
one of the main parts of this machine
being honest as the biggest streamer on
the platform
oh yeah i can't imagine the amount of
money what the [ __ ]
this is
this is gonna eat itself alive yo this
is like a dragon eating its tail
this is gonna come to a head because
this [ __ ] is so shady it's so [ __ ] up
it's integrated and twitch in all the
fundamental
ways from the top up
and i i
i think i said this
last year when we talked about this and
the fact that it still has not
hit
the mainstream press
as a massive scandal that this website
that is primarily used by children let's
let's be honest yep
the biggest streamers on the platform
are just
slamming slots for eight to 14 hours a
day this is [ __ ] insane this whole
thing is going to explode one day i
don't know when but it's going to be
catastrophic for everybody involved
and twitch
i mean and the fact they haven't banned
him yet it's like why not okay don't ban
gambling but why not him he's a scammer
he's scammed exactly people because that
just admits that
that you can't do that why why can't
they he's scamming literal users of
twitch
like youtube reserves that right they
say like if someone is damaging the
ecosystem for other people we reserve
the right to
sure that's in twitch's tos too but i
mean it's clearly a conscious choice and
it's like it's hard to
i'm not saying that this is what's going
on but
at this point
it's hard for me to not start thinking
like
somebody high up at twitch like own a
piece of steak or something like what
the [ __ ] is going on it is hard like how
have they not acted on this it's hard to
imagine that level of corruption because
it's like jeff bezos owns it it's amazon
you know they run a tight ship i'm sure
but
ultimately you might i mean i guess it's
possible that one person high up and and
setting policy is getting like an insane
kickback from steak i don't know
it's hard it's hard to say that you know
it's hard yeah i mean i'm not saying
that that's what's going on but it
crosses your mind it's hard to not start
thinking like there has to be something
deeper going on because it's just so
irrational for them to be completely
passive about this it is it really is
what are we going to say love there's a
pretty interesting thing that i heard a
person called devin nash talk about the
other day he's like a
big shot he's the owner of like gaming
orcs and stuff ex-owner and he knows a
lot about these things apparently the
reason i'm sorry the reason amazon
bought twitch was not to
be the big big shots in streaming they
wanted the streaming technology and they
actually make their a lot of money more
money than from the streaming platform
twitch itself in selling
the actual live streaming service to
other companies if that makes sense like
the underlying technology yeah yeah the
software no that makes sense
so they actually he david nash said like
the top people don't give a [ __ ] about
uh people on twitch or yeah i mean on
there i think another money maker i
think the high ups in amazon don't give
a single [ __ ] about twitch just because
it's not making money i mean i don't
think twitch is making money i don't see
how it's even possible it's not maybe
they break even at best
but um
here is one of his this was actually she
was this girl hat you
was apparently really good friends with
him
he says sorry
sorry i have a huge problem right now i
don't even have that much on stream
because of depression
look i believed you at least try to pay
me back it's still a really tough
situation for me
and i really need the money she told him
and he says please please send me he's
asking please please
really sad and that i really depression
but at least i need to try
but he just said he even didn't try you
know what money was even doesn't matter
at the time
i just said because he just
he just didn't think about me
he just didn't
give a [ __ ] about me
i thought he was my friend
at least he
was trying to
he should try to
oh
it's just interesting to think that like
stick [ __ ] steak or companies like
they're the only best beneficiary of
this
grief this horrific
the wake of destruction like the
gambling addict doesn't benefit anything
the people he's stealing money from
doesn't benefit anything steak and
companies like it are the only ones that
end up with the money
well
twitch is juicing views off the drama
it's not just like you said slicker he's
kind of benefiting from it he's not
banned he's getting lots of views that
is [ __ ] mind-blowing that that man is
not how is he not banned like what the
[ __ ] and he's just he's hundreds of
thousands of dollars
i was checking out his page yesterday it
was like oh he was live two hours ago
yeah he's just living it up
you know people people keep pointing out
like either ms kif or or xuc they're
giving these people their money back
which is good obviously that the victims
are getting repaid but it's like this is
clearly a systemic problem
they're being paid off by the [ __ ]
people promoting the god damn
right well in executive's case i don't
think
i think gambled a long time ago but i
don't think he's no i'm not talking
about yeah talking about xqc and
trainwreck right love says that he had
10k viewers on his past two streams
whereas his average is 1k so this has
been a huge uh benefit to him
oh yeah it's crazy
great great uh
marketplay there yeah here's xqc trying
to convince train wreck the two biggest
gambling streamers
to pay back the people scammed let's see
it was stand by slicker you know what
i'll throw an offer out there i'll throw
it off right there okay i'll throw a
curveball okay and i will stick to my
word if train wants to
if he wants to join force with me on a
50 50 split okay
i will refund
half
of everybody who's been scammed of any
money a singular dollar
with proof we'll go through all of them
and we'll refund them if you want to go
550.
how about that
i'm sorry you just don't get to be the
good guy
when you're the one causing this problem
i'm sorry it's [ __ ] up
it's just it's insane
no free good will for no good will for
you bro
like i'm i'm a good that that makes you
feel better but you guys are still
responsible for this and when the dust
settles man they're gonna have a lot to
answer for those two guys
it's gonna be a lot
it feels like hush money yeah maybe a
little bit i mean that was yeah it's
like settled
it's like nda's money yeah yeah don't
rock the boat here steak is my cash cow
then people start to question it and
then fbi maybe gets involved
exactly was my my gut instinct as well
when i heard that that sounds like
damage control to me sounds like an
investment yeah
scamming people
dude
i'm i'm also a little bit curious how
does train
give slicker one hundred thousand
dollars from canada to england that is
impossible which i think it was probably
crypto crypto right because they're not
yeah
there's no way to pay that you can do
that uh legally
oh i see what you mean like tax wise
yeah i mean probably no it's definitely
not like impossible well well so to do
it legally train would have to
he would have to acknowledge it on his
taxes as a gift
and then it would make
silker liable to pay
income tax on it depending on his
jurisdiction right but i'm sure he's not
doing that
right
it's on it's basically on slicker to
report that as income so he's the one
breaking the law yeah
all right which i don't think he i don't
think he has any problem doing that
clearly fair enough but that's a good
point that's a ton of money changing
hands you need to report that stuff and
that's the other thing too i don't know
where slicker lives i don't even know
what country's in but um
if he was in the u.s
i mean this is beyond like tos [ __ ] at
this point like
oh it's a crime it's fraud yeah it's
like
all kinds of fraud like this is serious
jail time territory in the uk
but i don't i don't think
their laws on this [ __ ] is very
different than ours that's not fraud
it is fraud damn it i would call that uh
false advertising no y'all roll he
straight up lied to them it's not false
advertising let's figure out how to dig
ourselves out of this [ __ ]
that's a steak ladies and gentlemen
yeah this shit's nuts man
twitch man i'll give you be honest
i've always hated twitch as a platform
and ever since they dumped us like
unceremoniously
i've always thought that they just
suck as a platform
which sucks to say because the employees
there that i met are awesome super sweet
great people people that work at twitch
but as an organization
it [ __ ]
is horrible like toxic even um
really bad
yeah and i mean after years of working
on the show and being on youtube
primarily i mean youtube is far from a
perfect platform but when it comes to
um
being
at least remotely consistent with like
enforcing it rules and everything i mean
youtube is way better about it than
twitch and yeah just the way that
they're so arbitrary about how they i
mean the fact that this guy
is not banned at this point tells you
everything you need to know whereas you
know hassan caught a ban for saying
cracker it's like why that's so true you
know what i mean like it's [ __ ]
crackered
yeah they ban they ban women for showing
too much cleavage
you know what i mean like they ban
people for the most arbitrary [ __ ] and
then here is just clear-cut he admits to
it he's
on the users not just other creators but
like the subs like people that use the
website you're he's defrauding your
users
not like not like a little fraud like it
sounds like this guy stole like hundreds
of thousands if not a million dollars
like this is grand grand fraud here
insane
high level crimes
yeah [ __ ] twitch i'm so done with that
seven day ban for saint cracker
it's just like what is that you can't
say cracker i mean this still blows my
mind
crack it cracker still no no explanation
for why doctor disrespect was banned
actually
nothing isn't that amazing
one of the greatest mysteries of all
internet history really is it's so
awesome i would pay to know that i would
pay a lot of money to know that
well there it is guys uh twitch
continues to be the best it's the best
the undisputed
greatest platform out there
[Applause]
and actually i'm super happy to announce
my new sponsor steak maybe twitch later
a little bit later today with that music
zach let's hear it
i'm happy here to announce that i will
be uh redeeming all of
[Music]
slick's uh
victims
go ahead and use uh slick 40
get 40 free dollars if you sign up today
at stake
he's going to jail that's right 40.
let's go hey ethan can i have 300 000
i know you got it i got you bro but
we're done after this all right deal
all right
yes
slot machines
big money
it's sports betting that's the problem
okay let's go
let's play some slots
steak.com h3 i trust them
i think you can too i trust fake.com
that's just alone
big difference is how you pay it back
[Laughter]
and it's become your family's heart and
soul it really is stink.com h3
so you can retire better
somebody in the chat said xqc tweeted he
gambled 1 000 and made 1.5 million and
he's using it to pay all the debt don't
care oh that's great
hey you can get
the solution i'm gonna go dude that's it
if only slicker would have gambled
harder and longer that's right won and
paid them back yes yes yes yes how did i
not see it before free money it's free
money
xqc only refunded people if they made a
steak account
no
to apply for uh
debt forgiveness
refunding imbalance
avery said he sent the clip hey
dan you think gambling's a problem it's
you're the problem let's go
this isn't my first rodeo
it's steak.com
come visit our hut
[Music]
all right
all right i can't put this off any
longer
right oh wait so we have uh
some prep work to do while you're
setting that up
yeah so
all right guys
i've been getting a lot of [ __ ] from
people's from ladies out there's
boyfriends
and i'm sick of it
i'm sick of people thinking me as a soy
you guys got to see this
i love when you guys post these by the
way so keep it up
guys i've been seeing this has turned
out to be a real high value man
everybody i'm so lucky
he says h3 is a [ __ ] r word and not
in a good way which i find did we i find
that interesting because
yeah what's the good version of the uh
of the r word there
[ __ ]
thank you quartering that is the word i
was referencing
well that just breaks my heart because i
thought it was one of the good uh uh
can i say that word
can i say it or
something jeremy say it for you
maybe jeremy will say it for me yeah
yeah yeah i i i it breaks my heart
because i thought i was one of the good
[ __ ] yeah
uh she said why though because
interviews suck
and he's an unprepared idiot
he's completely unable to handle his
platform correctly
wow
talk about a critic this guy is a deep
analysis
he got his
thank you shredder
he got his rise
and fame from good content
and then his content sucked when he ran
out of ideas
and now the podcast is all he has left
dude is seeth this inability
you're bringing some alpha male energy
she said you are blind
i love how he flips on her so [ __ ]
hard bro
like
like she's not even really
she's kind of just goofing around like
mad alpha energy you are blind
[ __ ] and this is my favorite he goes
his bill burr interview
and doc disrespect interviews are an
example that [ __ ] happened like five
years ago
yeah i don't know what's his beef with
the doctor disrespect one
you know the bill the first bill burr
interview is h3 lore obviously but that
happened like five years ago and we had
a second one people forget we had a
second one that was great
he says i'm straight up unprepared and
winged it again five years ago
his interview his interviews have
actually significantly improved since
those examples and i find it unlikely
you've watched thank you queen
you're but i hate to tell you queen but
you applaud
it's incredible how much they hate me
though like he passionately [ __ ]
hates me
it's not even like that's not my cup of
tea
i used to be a fan but you know i just
stopped watching
it's passion
it's incredible
it's like
the alpha males
being a fan threatens almost their
self-identity as an alpha male
yeah i'm not sure he says i'm seeds i
see the inability i was
also feeling like that wasn't a proper
usage of the word seeds
or inability it just makes doesn't that
make much sense
beta behavior that's just one okay we
have had so many posts and look here's
another one
keep them coming by the way ladies
told the tinder date that i watch h3 and
i'm a current member he literally
laughed out loud he said i don't [ __ ]
with h3 a lot because he's like strongly
against working out which i think is
kind of weird
oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that love i
glanced over at you let me see that
again
oh hold on hold on yo are you against
working out bro
yeah bro oh
i thought it was like a fat filter
dude it's incredible the uh reach that
these alpha exercise guys have
they've turned they're all turned
against me i'm against working out
people who work out are enemies
if you work out i don't want to be your
friend
if you work out you're not allowed in my
house we don't welcome your types
working out's for pansies and losers and
women
get down you work out what are you a
woman
that's just another one
baby you're making these jokes but this
is going to turn up on the next uh
tiktok compliment
here's another one i brought up the
podcast with the guy meeting in person
in a week
h3 podcast i wasn't lying i don't know
dude i might have to ghost you i love h3
lola i'm just kidding i watched them for
years he was funny like six years ago
not sorry dude's so fat
and gross
and tells people tells people they
shouldn't talk about health [ __ ]
fat ugly and stupid
he's kind of a hypocrite his vague
nation video was legit funny though
it's like
it's just the infamy i have like infamy
as somehow
and it all boils down to fat
batman bad
bad ugly and stupid
fat man bad fat ugly and stupid skinny
man good strong man good
how i'm sorry to ladies ladies how are
you
it must be really hard out there to meet
a man if this is the [ __ ] you're
encountering
he literally criticized me because i'm
fat and gross to a date
yeah a lot of boys that's what men are
like out there for real
like some of them
a lot of them
and actually most of these girls are it
seems like they've been talking to him
for a few days or even a week and it's
like damn
yeah sometimes people will uh come out
of left field
can you imagine saying that i don't like
him he's fat and gross yeah you just
like being on dating apps
as a girl i'm sure guys go through
their own separate thing and
um
the people
blah blah blah you know what i'm saying
okay
what was i saying i don't know what
you're saying
that everyone has their thing you think
they're [ __ ] girls too
it's just you're prepped to
to respond to various situations like if
i get
a certain text like send pics
i'll be like oh okay i i know this
situation and this the the right wing
situation is
it's one that you're prepped for
and the the women are lesser than yeah
i've a few so you think this is a right
wing like a conservative guy thing going
on here yeah yeah
here's another one
me and my co-workers were getting along
and playing fortnight together until i
told them i'm an h3 fan now i'm scared
these people were friends they were
playing videos together video games
together tonight
she said me and my boyfriend are
watching the h3 pod ugh
and also what's that
those two sentences
the h3 podcast is a comedy podcast on
youtube oh my [ __ ] god i remember him
from back in the day he fell off
i don't think so i still like his stuff
today why don't you like him super
reasonable by the way right super nice
he's fat bro how do you type that
he literally says why don't you like him
he's fat
he's fat and tells little boys that
working out is bad for them [ __ ]
what little boys it's like i'm doing i'm
doing i'm going around kindergarten
giving speeches [ __ ]
yo
if you exercise
you don't you don't be around my kid
what the i mean it's like the
the boogie manification of me is kind of
crazy i'm more interested in the next
line actually he's a sellout to his fans
selling out
she said that means selling out as in
like
bending to the will of your fans or a
sellout to his fans well let's see she
says sell out how
he used to be chill
but now he's afraid to say anything
because people form a mob he's a [ __ ]
now oh i know what happened he read that
jordan peterson tweet
where jordan's like one day
one day
one day
i lost it
one day you will bow
to your wok mob and they'll come for you
next [ __ ]
he used to be chill
sell out how he used to be chill bro
oh my god i wish i want these guys to to
watch though they need me these guys
need me more than anyone
oh sorry no no go ahead they just they
give you so much power it's crazy they
think so much about me i'm such a boogie
man in their world
usually you're just like what are your
interests xyz cool what are yours people
really have a lot to say when when they
give their podcast to them
you could have just he could have just
been like cool like i'm not a big fan of
his yeah literally i used to watch him
back in the day i don't really watch
them anymore
that's fine even that is telling enough
low-key though
no i mean
that's right yeah i mean there are no
there are things that i used to watch
that i don't watch anymore and it's not
because i dislike them you just your
taste change olivia's right but that is
the pipeline that's that's the that's
the go-to you got to be careful man
there's a lot of clowns out there
wow that was good wow i did enjoy that
wow that was great
also i was gonna say i've been caught in
4k it's from zach yeah i saw that yeah a
little joker brain action yeah split
personality yeah dude i don't even
remember that
he continues look all i'm saying is
every time i see him anywhere it's
because he's being a beta [ __ ] yeah
it's probably because you're on tater
talk
and i used to be a fan of the podcast
until you started apologizing for
everything
okay
apologies are for women
i don't even know what he's talking
about yo
only [ __ ] apologize
beta red flag love that
yeah
what about it lol don't tell me you're
going to spazz out
what do you think of andrew taylor she's
right on the money
[Music]
oh boy
you wouldn't be the type right on the
target his content isn't for you
is it for you he changed my life
and made me want to speak my mind and
not care to be silenced by the mob
he gave men a voice when people wanted
to remove it
playing fortnite oh bro chill you're
playing fortnite
yeah so these are the people uh
these are the people
yes but
it's not okay because i wanna
you know i want to grow the channel i
want
that's the game that's the game i want
people to
i want them to come back the fallen fans
i need to prove to them that i am indeed
alpha
i do think i'm more alpha than andrew
tate i do shut up
it's just a matter of fact i'm more
alpha
life's too short to exercise here's one
here's just an example this one has a
1.5 million views 200 000 likes
so let's see here we go life's too short
to exercise i'm just going to be honest
there's so many you can even hear people
laughing in the background that's me
like
thank you zach
i'm not like delivering a ted talk
saying don't exercise
better things to do than exercise it is
a shame for a man to grow by the way
this is from uh
berserk
oh this is berserk oh maybe not no it's
that one
it sounds like the opening uh what's
this it's an anime where everyone's
super jacked jojo no no
[ __ ] what's it called i've watched it
it's pretty good talk about the old
school one no no it's it just came out
on netflix baki baki
yeah it's like a weird met it's like a
muscle fetish [ __ ] like
to be honest i like it but
the muscle animations are really
kind of sexual
without seeing the beauty and strength
of which his body is capable socrates
was very interested in that yeah oh yeah
socrates was interested in [ __ ]
touching a little baby's dick
how do you feel about that sex
good yo dude you're jacked let's [ __ ]
go
it's awesome
do it oh it's so awesome
so that one has 1.5
this one has 2 million there's all so
many of these i don't have time to show
you all of them life's too short to
exercise i'm just going to be on it
i love that i became a meme on gym talk
250 000 likes 2 million views there's so
many better things to do than exercise
it is a shame for a man to grow old
without seeing the beauty and strength
of which his body is capable
yeah oh yes
[ __ ] yes oh
let's see all the sounds that use this
yo i'm [ __ ] owning this [ __ ]
six thousand three hundred and thirteen
look at all these life's too short to
exercise i'm just gonna be honest yeah
so many better things to do than
exercise
life's too short to exercise this one
has uh
five hundred thousand too short to
exercise i'm just gonna be honest
there's so many better things to do than
exercise it is a shame for a man to grow
old without seeing the beauty and
strength of which his body is capable
you know what's so awesome about like
weightlifting community it's just a
bunch of dudes like checking each other
out
i don't think from what i understand i
don't think women
prefer this body type to like others
i mean i'm sure some women do
i still have anything i saw someone do
like a survey of like
body types that women prefer
and the super muscly guys
were not anywhere near the top but
anyway
all the top comments are about me
why ethan such an l now
well so many better things to do does
none of them
how do you know
grammatical errors all over the place
doesn't really make any sense
i guarantee those types of people never
took it seriously that's why
justin look at him no wonder why he says
that lol the creator said he never did
what the [ __ ] you know me
he sits in a chair all day
doing the worst podcast what else is he
doing
love it man
so gym talk was really prolific with
this it's pretty pretty interesting it
is a shame for a man oh you used to be a
fat loser like me [ __ ]
look at that sunday you fat [ __ ]
i bet you ate that whole thing huh fatty
life's too short to
exercise so let's see
i love the self-loathing that like sex
people have for themselves it's like you
were fat your whole life
now what fat people are like the biggest
[ __ ] losers in the world because you
you got your [ __ ] together
[Music]
[Music]
the poses are so crazy
like he's
so
glamorous with it
i used
all of it look at that big old smile
look how happy he is to eat that [ __ ]
sundae
daddy who's really nice loki
yeah like he looks like he would be a
very kind kind guy yeah he looks like a
teddy bear
let's see if there's any comments about
me
i mean good for him but i don't see why
you got to put other people down
i used to be a fat [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
anyway actually all the comments here
about him that's nice
but um
pretty interesting
little uh meme there on tater talk
yeah
well you know what [ __ ] them
i'm gonna prove here now are we ready to
for the uh yeah i guess so um
i'm here to prove all you taylor talks
wrong
that i am an alpha male
exercising is not what makes you alpha
let's be honest
let's be honest
i'm richer than you
i've got a beautiful family
my wife loves me we're about to have a
10 year anniversary
i've got a meaningful job that i love i
work with people that i love what's not
alpha about that
you know what's [ __ ] beta
is going to a gym and salivating over
another man's body all day that's fine
that's just gay but it's fine
is that a dude coming
that's great ball
that's big ball that's grateful you know
what's beta
listening to other people tell you how
to run your [ __ ] life
be your own man that's beta oh daddy
andrew tate tell me how to live better
really walk their own path i felt
worthless [ __ ]
i felt ugly that's right
keep going i felt gay
that's the worst of all like that's
based on what they told me
[Music]
i'm sorry
but i'm here to show you what real
alphas look like
they look like me
they look like dan dan's alphas [ __ ] bro
cameron alpha
love alpha chad omega
zack
zack is something else
i'll take that but he's not a beta no
he's he's uh what's the what's like the
greek uh
for jay
they gotta have one
jalfa
alpha alpha brand job of rain
dude ian is so [ __ ] alpha i mean take
a look at this guy
go ahead ian that is the face of an
alpha male
i'm serious he has a massive penis like
these guys who talk about alpha all day
they're such sheep they really are
they're they're just members of a
[ __ ] herd
that makes them feel superior but you
guys are actually the betas okay
got nothing to do with physical strength
i appreciate that thank you you're
welcome ian the alpha is in your heart
okay i got some muscles
you do let's see him
oh my god
do you exercise sometimes
sometimes there it is we got the gym
back there in our office i mean that's
how alpha we are we have the gym in our
studio
how much is how much weight you got
there love
uh let's see i think it's like um
it looks to be around uh
24 pounds
wow
yeah but alpha's not about how much the
weight weighs it's about how much
of a weight you don't let society weigh
on your heart
abs alpha is [ __ ] we all know that
are we ready dan
okay so
all right so this is proving to you all
all you alphas at home listen and watch
here we go
first of all i've got alpha brain
this [ __ ] is so [ __ ] expensive talk
about sheep i know i'm it's hard not to
react you guys paid like 60 bucks for 30
of these alpha brains
and you're accusing me of being a beta
you're literally cocked to alpha brain
[ __ ] you show up at work and then you're
supposed to take four a day right olivia
i think
serving size two capsules
and it
says suggested use
okay take two
per day
that's four bucks a day
so here you go guys
it doesn't matter
okay here we go
who's more alpha now
how much [ __ ] alpha brain is that
lunchtime [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
just like science that alpha brain is
good stuff
dude you're just like socrates
soccer teams would have eaten that more
alpha brain i'm not on that level yet
bro does it taste like mussels
it tastes like a bunch of dog [ __ ]
it tastes like beef jerky
you know what's one of the health
benefits you want to know how this is
legit it says promotes flow state
state ladies and gentlemen
not taking a pause to pee
uh they don't define what flow state is
unfortunately
could be how well i urinate closely
okay 10 alpha brains down what's next
simulated hunt
joe rogan hunts with the spear i hunt
with my [ __ ] hands or he hunts with
the bow i hunt with my hands
this is my trident
this is what i always go hunting with
this is there's a little echo this is my
hunting weapon of choice like poseidon
himself only [ __ ] and bettas and
fools use hunting bows
rifles
really dark in the shot very beta of you
dad there you go
pretty darn okay whatever
yeah it's bryan where are we we're uh
you're being sub primal right now yeah
you're being really surprised all right
wait wait wait wait wait hold on you
need your hunting buddy
come on
love join me bro we about to open the
[ __ ] up and you know i hear beta's
talking about using
guns rifles nah the real thrill of the
hunt is in hand-to-hand combat with the
spear let's go though leave the church
buddy okay
leave the charge but i'm right behind
you there's your uh there's your prey
over there you see that right behind you
there buddy yeah i see
right i'm just letting love leave the
charts
all false
a grizzly one of the most deadly ones
all
right eat this
dude
[Music]
some technical difficulties we'll get
back to the hunt momentarily
[Music]
i'd like to see joe rogan go toe-to-toe
with the grizzlies we good yeah we're
back yeah
yeah anyway
there's some real alpha [ __ ] bro
[Music]
by the way [ __ ] the little mermaid being
black
i gotta tried it like her dad
and we all know she's white
[Music]
that little mermaid is white excuse me
love
oh that was pretty good
pretty good yeah that was really good
that's the primal go ahead love your
turn
just scream the little mermaid is white
as you
yeah yeah yeah spear you know i was
father we're not fast
just remember the bat the battle cry
love
okay i don't know if i want to do that
logan made his way
little uh bermuda
um is this speaker not working
what's the little mermaid white hello
yeah i'm speaking on this
okay so she was white right
right yeah okay
well bro what
you want to square up what are you
saying
oh [ __ ]
what are you saying dude
[Music]
bro what are you saying it doesn't even
make sense to devote
[Music]
and that's what happens bro when you
talk [ __ ]
that that's what happens
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
all right let's go wow the final moment
dude
impressive
thank you
it doesn't make sense
you wouldn't even be black at the bottom
of the seat because there's no light
but doesn't scientifically make sense
[Music]
[Applause]
send this to your boyfriends ladies
but we're not done yet
elk they say
there's many things they say make the
man
but in my opinion it's the elk me
that makes them in
healthy
it's like
remember how they're all like elf me and
egg yolk is healthier
yeah
sub subprime
right flesh hitting bacteria no
[Music]
yeah you know what you could wash that
meat down with
i'll eat all these
send this to your boyfriends ladies
hey hey alpha tick-tock
this is me with a cigar cutter
this is your [ __ ] [ __ ]
this is what happens when you when you
try to step and we step to me with your
alpha [ __ ]
yeah
no i don't beat my wife and children
[Music]
who's ready to play
let's go
smoke a car
[Music]
i'm gonna go rip a dart
dark
dark
[Music]
he's smoking a car dude
oh yeah oh that looks
tasty a big fat brown [ __ ] turd in
the mouth
nothing manlier than that oh yeah as a
meat too
dude
whoa
[Music]
more alphabet
yes
[Applause]
there's nothing more alpha than mouth
cancer
and now for the biggest show the biggest
tour de force you've seen yet
do you think i give a [ __ ] about some
cold weather in an ice bath then you
don't know me ethan alpha climb no i do
want to point out we poured all the ice
in and it it
it pretty much instantly melted
but it is cold as [ __ ]
confirmed to the people okay
the temperature here
oh it's freezing and you can see some of
the ices there yeah no it's
it's very cold uh do i have a chain is
there a change of clothes here for me uh
lena how should i how should i go in we
have a change of clothes ready for you
go in no shirt
we don't have extra underwear
oh
well go in my underwear no go alpha it's
commando dude
i'll just go naked it's no problem
it's a problem no it's a problem
no i ian will blurry underwear
i need like a chase cam here so you guys
can see me submerged in this
i'm just
i'm making sure the little hole doesn't
open
this is a loose hole guys
it's a loose hole
i don't want to do a dick out i'm
shooting you from the waist up
here i'll do it like this just
because if my dick comes out i don't
want to get
by the way what do you guys think 15
pounds down yeah
looking good my boy looking good even
more
try to get a shot in the tub please
now all you mother [ __ ] beta ass
[ __ ]
[Music]
think that taking an ice bath is the
pinnacle
of alpha
technology
now me a fat overweight jewish
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] loser is about to
dip into the ice of oblivion
with a guard
oh my god oh no don't complain no
complaining
[ __ ] that's cold
[ __ ]
think about rogan what's that moment
come on
okay don't show my crotch in case it
pops up
give me a burger give me a [ __ ] help
me dude
[ __ ] you give me a big hurry i need to
warn my [ __ ]
look inside it's freaky bro
no you can't see my dear come to make
sure
no no
all right
all right
show it ian
show it
you got me some alphabet
[Music]
no thanks
[Applause]
here's your clip here talking your heart
out
i just got done eating some seared
testicles
eat your heart out alphas who's your
alpha king now [ __ ]
throw the proof of the meat in dan
we have frozen hamburgers throw it in
show them what real out real outfits
bathe
and frozen meat patties [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
that's raw beef [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] are you
that's raw beef
that's alpha brain
and that's a guard
i'm happy man i'm chilling bro i'm
totally comfortable in here ain't no
problem you can show and you can see
hey
that's raw meat wait are these cooked
actually no those are raw broth that's
raw meat who the [ __ ] bathes with raw
meat but me
nobody
i got a body like alex jones how are you
gonna accuse me of being
how are you gonna accuse me of being a
beta when i look like alex jones just a
little less red
that's right baby
oh yeah i'm liberal you know what i
inhaled that
i held that whole [ __ ] thing
here is ethan klein oh
jesus that was a i ripped that dart so
[ __ ] hard and this is how we do it
i'll do the whole show like this man
do a temperature check on this water
easily below 30. easily
[Music]
it's not even a problem for me
it's not even a problem
this is how we do it
so go ahead ask me any questions in the
chat this is your alpha lord
uh i actually have a uh little quiz i
could give you an alpha clause
okay
i wish people knew how cold this was
because all the ice is melted up yeah
it's cold as [ __ ] it's over four bags of
ice so
all right so uh
question number one do you work out bro
do you even lift
lifting's for betas next
so not at all
i mean i'm i lift basically the whole
male community on my back does that
count oh so i don't need to work out my
body is naturally in good shape yes and
also you can call me atlas now because i
carry the world on my shoulders next
uh do you prefer uh sports or video
games sports easily every time got it do
you respect women
no [ __ ] women
no losers idiots subclass
would you rather have a lasting
relationship or a string of one night
stand one night stan's
commitment is for losers and idiots
there's always a better opportunity over
the corner okay do you maintain eye
contact when you're talking absolutely
never look away i walked into our trip i
was in the bathroom once and i opened a
stall that i thought was unoccupied
there was a man [ __ ] there and we
locked [ __ ] eyes for a minute because
i refused to look away i refused to
[ __ ]
bow down
and then
he left he actually finished [ __ ] he
wiped his ass and he left that's how
alpine i was from that's awesome never
unlock eyes go
uh what is your political affiliation
are you a liber
the four classical parties liberal
capitalist anarcho-capitalism
or i'm not into politics i'm a
capitalist baby money
cream cream makes the money go around
that's right
get that dollar bill y'all
how tall are you
way over six feet six feet are over i
love that your height determines your
alphaness of course it does
uh what is your hourly wage uh i will
point out i'm not a wage slope i
couldn't even count i couldn't even
count i'm gonna go ahead and say i'm not
a wage slave no no
uh a masked intruder breaks into your
home what do you do do you call the
police release the hounds try to reason
with them or defend your home and family
with your weapons or your bare hands
that one obviously but i have like foam
alone style traps over my [ __ ] house
bro i got marbles and fox you won't even
[ __ ] know
uh how many how big of a family do you
want as many kids as possible triplets
two kids one child's enough i want my
kids to not even know their dad let me
ask let me answer in that way so as many
as possible as many as possible these
kids are not even know my [ __ ] name
by when i'm done having kids sick sick
sick uh would you forgive a girl if she
cheated on you i kill her
i bury her
um i don't see i kill her i would bury
that [ __ ] if she ever [ __ ] cheated
on me do you understand how about okay
interesting that doesn't sound very i
think if i'm reading between the lines
the alpha
rule here is that you don't actually
give a [ __ ] that she cared about you in
the first i kill her
okay well i guess we'll just skip that
one she's dead yeah
uh are you an extrovert or an introvert
i'm technology oh that's the thumbnail
bro i don't even [ __ ] know what that
means dude i'm just alpha what are you
talking about right
are you good at telling jokes obviously
everybody loves me
yeah i'm a pro i'm a bass i'm a
professional comedian
do you like parties i live for parties
bro everywhere but everywhere it goes a
party right you bring the party
uh when did you learn lose your
virginity
okay
uh what kind of education do you hold
education's for [ __ ] idiots i i hold
a phd on live you learn everything you
need to know from the internet exactly
phd in life
do you believe in children
hold on dan hold on go ahead hit the
software okay
okay could be a bite of the outfit
uh do you believe in traditional values
obviously women but belong in the
kitchen
uh okay
[Music]
uh
do you have trouble breaking up with
girls never i just killed them no no i
just killed him are you a natural leader
yes
born
how competitive are you i will [ __ ]
literally hurt people over a game of
pinball i don't give a [ __ ] i'll win
every competition period how's your
posture alpha what do you mean erect and
dominant always
i'm homo erectus posture [ __ ] okay
are you a loud person what
the [ __ ]
uh what's your handshake technique so
strong
uh you try and crush the other person's
hand in a show of dominance is that is
that your answer it's a successful
handshake if they need to visit a doctor
afterwards right okay
uh how emotional are you
emotions are for women
right uh i'm gonna go with that one then
uh what kind of car do you drive
is a sports car yeah you drive a sports
car
okay
uh what do you like to drink
budweiser whatever it's whatever gets it
done bro actually i don't drink change
it i only let the woman drink i'm sober
right okay yeah that's very easier to
seal the deal
uh one in a busy street how do you walk
what the [ __ ] is this question
you
guys hold on kev look at this you wanna
know how else i am i'm putting the cigar
out in my [ __ ] pool next
damn light me up [ __ ]
thank you baby new guard
you lighting up a new guard i never
stopped oh okay uh
when in a busy street how do you walk uh
i don't even look two ways [ __ ] the
world stops for me you understand what
i'm saying
when i cross the street the cars better
look both ways okay this one seems to
kind of check from some of those boxes
uh are you okay with an open
relationship
i can [ __ ] whoever i want the women can
never cheat or i killed them
uh eg
i guess that's this one uh to what
extent do you agree with the following
statement the weak should fear the
strong they should easy done completely
they do they should they do
right is it better viewed by women as
the nice guy or a badass do i even
answer that
your [ __ ] dad for even asking me that
question yeah that's true i am a [ __ ]
uh do you avoid conflict never claw
fifth is my way of life
you seek conflict yeah no right
uh do you always try your hardest
that's like a trick question about
everything i do is to the max
try my hardest
are you serious my existence is try hard
everything i do is [ __ ] 11 out of 10.
[ __ ] i'm gonna go with yes then
uh when a relationship ends how long
does it take for you to move on
immediately i'll [ __ ] the next girl
after i'm done burying the other girl's
body
instantly okay instantly
uh to what extent do you agree with the
following statement i have more female
friends than male friends
i have no female friends they're only
subjects do you have male friends
only my brother
right okay so friends are just
a distraction right i have my brother
and people that pay me next cool
uh
you put others first or you put yourself
first
bro are you stupid
the world doesn't exist outside my
[ __ ] brain why should i put someone
else through first who's the nbc
next
uh that seems to be it let's see oh
what do you know
it's official everyone
he's an alpha male 1
[Applause]
top g
sub g
you can call me at the top e
top e
careful about
showing down in my dips away
there it is guys one more for tick tock
you ready
elk meat done
alpha brain
consumed
gar
ninth one of the day
[Applause]
i literally
i literally have heartburn up full
chunks of meat
do you know what alpha means
[Laughter]
i don't have stomach bile i have [ __ ]
i just have
meat blood chunks
how i digest right they just it's kind
of like a mechanical process and that's
just how we do it thank you
point proven oh the guard goes in the
bath the alpha brain to make the water
oh it's all gone
you ate it all it's all gone hey joe
rogan do you take baths in alpha brain
no is this sawdust what is happening
yeah sawdust asbestos and rat poison
all right yeah the main camera's fine
who wants to try to who's in this next
he wants to take a bath in this i am not
getting in there
stay on me as he stands up and do it
there's a little slip there oh good
all right ab wants to show you guys how
cold this water is because i want to
prove to all the alphas get a look at it
look how clean and pure this water is
did you get that feedback come come look
at the water cameron
hold on
come look in the water this is what
outfit water looks like you think clear
waters but
no this is what's up
that's alpha brain cigar ash and raw
meat who are you
they call me a beta who
all right i'm getting up
don't show my dick ian
i can't afford to show my dad no no
[Applause]
jesus man
there's a bunch of towels next to the uh
thing
i'm just blocking ethan with my hand
right now
obviously the ice was melted
but that water's 30 degrees maybe go
ahead
are you getting anything or two
all right
in the bear costume
we're gonna have to get that dry cleaned
i'm not doing it bro that's freezing
water what are you doing
oh my gosh what is she getting in that
now oh that is drinking water no hell no
don't drink the water
don't drink the water
that's so awful of you to bathe in ethan
spit
no what are you doing
did he just drink it no he ate a raw
beef patty you guys are [ __ ] so gross
that is joker
brand eating the rabbit fatty hey joker
that give me a cigar that's that's raw
meat yeah put that on the back
yeah don't swallow that
don't swallow the rum
what are you doing zach
ew wait come back oh [ __ ]
dude
that is
literally foul this is horrific okay
zach this is too much for me and please
don't you drop the you grab raw meat on
the floor
joker
god all right thank you joker
that's good that's good joker content
right there
[Music]
hell yeah
he's disturbing the joker brain that was
joking as [ __ ] we're good here it are we
good can we end the show yeah i'm good
maybe thinks he's gonna get hypothermia
i think you're gonna get it i'm i'm
gonna start puking
do you think the suit keeps you warm a
little bit
all right guys
all right can you can you uh take us can
you go over to your normal seat and end
the show
yeah i bet
so do the math that was the stupidest
thing we've ever done do the [ __ ]
math
my toes are black do the math
okay
i'm experiencing gangrene do the math
alpha's [ __ ]
flow state pills is such a scam it's
like selling smart water when tap is
better flow states are just a state of
mind based on your surroundings free of
cost it's science originated from fear
death experience yeah i just i don't
know how you can
package uh flow state stuff but anyway
that's the show
spread this on tik tok can you guys make
tick tocks like ethan nation or
like you know how do it yeah yeah yeah
i'm on that [ __ ] dude alpha ethan and
spread this all over tick tock let him
know who's the real [ __ ] alpha boss
around here right
is zach joker after that i'm gonna
yes was pretty shocking i'm not gonna
also voted vote
lie
yeah
he stepped up i guess yeah zach you're
crushing it right now 70 yes let's go
you did you did what had to be done you
got to do what you got to do man
now we eat the hot chip we got one left
no
that would be a pretty joker brain show
zach
the guy just ate sigma come on dude okay
okay we gave you a chance to redeem
yourself but that's okay that's okay you
ate the raw meat
all right thanks for watching everybody
we'll be back on wednesday do we have
gravy on wednesday
gravy is wednesday yeah young gravy is
going to be a
special
and i'm finally gonna get to the bottom
of this addison race love triangle
hopefully
oh zach
yes just brush your teeth or something
nah dude
all right thanks everybody see you on
wednesday
[Music]
you